all right and we are
live the last word with little cognito
and ibontes
back on that friday campfire big things
to talk about
big guests to talk about what is going
on
e first of all yeah yes we got a big
guess
that's good first how are you doing sir
oh been busy in this uh
world of smallin you know the elites
have invaded the tower
no they've been invited to the tower
hanging out in the annex i'm surprised
drifter isn't chatting one but
uh it's been a crazy week to say the
least
lots to discuss but zero drama in the
community it's nice to see that destiny
community is like
calm nothing going on magic just
complete sarcasm we have so much to
discuss but before we do let's bring our
guest in because
we got to get his hot hot takes from all
of his personalities let's go
no doubt welcome to the last word
episode number 149
it is glorious friday we're back in
front of the campfire for some more
lunar shooter discussion
i'm extremely excited about our special
guest so we're going to get right into
it
i want to introduce the lord whose
ascension is one of the most
entertaining and family-friendly content
creators
he's only matched by his creative talent
and always
having his finger on the pulse of the
destiny community
introducing the creating host of the d
flawless twitch and youtube channels
the lord of the diamond club
best known for bringing light to your
day with the funniest
characters and go live skits in the game
live from nola and making his debut
at the campfire of the last word
my man lord d flawless how are you doing
man
i'm good man how are you that that intro
is epic
you a crown we do we should do that for
all of our guests be like hey can you
send this to this guy he's coming up
next
exactly i love it i love it how's
everybody doing thanks for having me
oh man we're happy to have you you've
been just absolutely killing it lately
you're
you're like on an explosive rise which
is awesome to watch and see somebody
who's like
just like doing his own thing and the
skits are hilarious and everybody's
loving you and your positivity is just
like
it's so nice to talk to you but so nice
to see someone like
you explode because like
certain like you never quite know what
person i was gonna take it but i was
like man if you don't i'm gonna be
surprised and just every time i see you
just bigger and bigger i'm like awesome
it's it's so cool to see yeah very cool
it's been fun for sure
you've been you've been a little busy
just like writing you know signing
contract after contract after
partnership
you know there's a dump truck full of
money right outside my house right now
so we gotta speed this up the truck
that's awesome
but yeah man tremendous essential love
what you're doing out here man so much
fun but
let's start with that uh story we're
gonna get into because we're gonna gotta
get into the game of history we gotta
see what's going on with you we see that
64 shirt so let's talk some gaming
origins man systems
no games that influenced you back in the
day so
yeah um so fun fact about this shirt
i'm i'm kind of an imposter right now
[Music]
and i've had just about every nintendo
gaming system
except the nintendo 64.
oh so you fraud are you frauding with
the shirt we got you now
we got you it was a nice shirt yeah this
is a shirt it was a nice shirt
so i got it you know i respect it my
friends had the nintendo 6.
yeah sleepovers and you know
stuff so i mean if you're in person what
what nintendo consoles did you
own slash play on so pretty much every
handheld
super nintendo um and
in the switch the gamecube were the
friend
gamecube and n64 were the friends system
so i would go
over there pretty regularly and and play
with them so
so like you got any awesome standout
games from your
from like the backlog like super
nintendo has just this collection of
crazy things and of course n64
what are some big games that you started
playing before you even got into destiny
so one of my favorite you know i grew up
on the classics right so we got super
mario
uh zelda link to the past like that's
the first game i remember beating
zelda link to the past that's a good
choice real young and
it took me like because you know back
then you couldn't just buy again it took
me like years to beat it
i was playing every day for like the
course of multiple years and just like
finally beating it
um talk about value for your money right
oh yeah um yeah game streams different
back then
madden sports games nice you know
really i didn't get into shooters until
like
uh right around towards the end of
middle school for me
or right before high school it was right
when halo came up
okay okay so whenever that was um
i played a little double-oh-seven like
like i said on some friend systems and
it was
it was fine i just wasn't hooked on
shooters
but when halo came out my brother got a
xbox
um and he didn't like shooting games he
was
he was strictly sports games but the
xbox came with halo preinstalled
so i just remember staying up the whole
night just
fire man did y'all do the co-op
did the co-op yeah the split screen oh
the split screen
look if if you weren't looking at your
friend's screen
it was either like some stupid reddit
thing or whatever and there's like one
guy they're trying to do split screen
and like a guy is hanging
from like a blanket in the ceiling to be
like in his split screen you know what
i'm talking about yes
that is dedication right there for like
the group split screen now
funny multiple versions of it i've seen
dudes put like
the cardboard above somebody's hand and
all
all type of joy just to try to make it
close to the tv
integrity oh my god it's hilarious
yes some friendships were tested with
the split screen for sure but
you know it's there you're not going to
look at it
so you got like mario you got some
platforming we got zelda
got a little action adventure do you
ever play any like big rpgs like you
ever go deep like
jrpg or anything because obviously we
know destiny's got his rpg elements did
you ever
dabble in that i'm a huge final fantasy
fan
final fantasy vii um first rpg
uh it's my favorite in the series
followed very closely and possibly tied
with final fantasy 10.
oh okay okay okay really like that so i
love the remake i'm excited for the
the addition to the remake that's coming
out integrated oh yeah
yeah i've never played seven ever so
integrated is gonna be my first okay
yeah you've got to change that bro like
that
i know but i didn't i missed it last
year when seven
seven came out i missed it i'd do a show
with him i know he's giving me a hard
time
but like i missed seven like right when
it came out because i kept waiting i was
like i want to get a nice monitor i want
to play it like
and then i was like i kept waiting and
then finally get to like the ps5 i'm
like well now i gotta wait for that
so yeah yeah yeah integrated now i
played chrono trigger like that's my rpg
so i got the jrpg but i was like i never
jumped into final fantasy i watched
seven and eight
through my brother so i saw like some of
the big like
what are the big giant spawns like what
are they the summons
yeah the summons i watched some of those
i'm like holy crap some of that stuff's
like amazing especially
like a ps2 i'm like how are you doing
that little system like i don't even
know what's happening right now so
no it always blew me away but i never
actually played through it personally so
i'll be
excited there's something funny about
final fantasy 7.
here's a here's the exclusive right
let's get it right
i still remember the guy's name and
hopefully you know if he's watching
uh anyway so i got
final fantasy vii i had a playstation i
didn't buy it i borrowed it from a
friend
i still have his disk
he wasn't playing the game i was like oh
man let me borrow it it looks like it's
pretty hot and it's cool
and and i'm just playing it and like
years go by i was like dude never asking
for this game
and we graduated school we lost contact
but you know
i remember his name was adam so adam if
you want your copy of final fantasy 7
back oh man at this point it's a
collector's edition
save that sucker
on the receiving and giving side of
those type of
game trades and exchanges when i
blend the game i was like all right i
need this back on monday at 5 30
you got a video story like a librarian
get like a video hit squad knock on the
little be like excuse me it's 5 31 we
need our video now yeah
exactly i can see the skit now just like
the dark suit and glasses walk up
yeah this afternoon there he goes they
said oh you got to say the dog we got to
see the dog outdoor man
yeah man so get good history and stuff
like that before we get more into i know
we're going to get into that
stuff but one thing i think is cool is
that your namesake is kind of
based also in with your profession so i
thought that was cool you know what i'm
saying like
how is that in the world of of being the
jeweler like
how does that go for you uh
it's fine i'm no longer a jeweler
nice recently but you know it's it's
still there i could i could still sell a
diamond
um if need be but yeah so
just long story short about that name
it's a name that i had before gaming
uh d flawless um because i was just
getting started in my jewelry career
um and come to you know my first name
starts with a d and then comes out come
to find out
the best type of diamond you can get is
it's a d flawless time it's a perfect
one
so so you know me and my little swag i
was like
you know i'm i'm good at this i'm d
flawless
and then my manager at the time he's
like all right d flaw so you just
started calling me d
floyd that's awesome that's fine
i did engagement ring shopping i know
exactly what you're talking about
because you got like the four
qualities and i was going yeah so yep
sadly i can tell you my wife's diamond
is not a d flawless
very few people right here
i'm at the level of it where i don't
even have to do it
you know i'm just i'm just thinking of
how i'm gonna let these people down easy
because you know they come in with
grandmama's ring
and they're like oh man i need this
you know how much you think this is
worth grandma said
[Laughter]
oh man did you ever
have anything come in that actually did
kind of blow you away that was like
damn this is actually worth a lot or was
most of it like kind of trash
okay oh yeah and it's always from
someone you don't expect they just got
this
huge you know perfect diamond
and they think it's fake and the ones
who think that
it's fake you know usually there's let
me check it out for you
like no it's just a perfect diamond sir
that's fine how much is this worth
uh i found this at costco parking lot
must have fallen out of that rich lady's
ring yes yes yes
off somebody's neck
like we're going to go ahead and need to
call you a police escort now so you
don't get muggles
this thing's worth three million dollars
please
no nothing that big but you know you see
some nice stuff for sure
that's what's up yeah man i had to ask
it had that
that's kind of a cool origin story like
i always wondered because
yeah it's like i went ring shopping
before so it's like the diamond club
this i was like that has to be like
it makes too much sense so you finally
explained it i was like i'm glad because
i was like
i know like the qualities and like the
fault like yeah it's like i went through
all that before
i was like i wish i knew my wife's off
hand i have it somewhere but yeah
like i wish i could i could tell you
like my wife's like all that stuff and
you'd be like so that's that's fine yeah
so usually when you know people post
like their engagement picks and they
show the ring i'm always
i'm always like looking at those other
all right let's see what you got over
here i'm trying to see if i can tell
through the picture
all right all right i got one
imperfection but it's lower blood
right yeah yeah i can't i can't bring
the jewels around deep flawless man
try to get exposed
hey have those cg's looking yeah those
look nice
[Laughter]
my biggest thing is is all right i'm
gonna vent a little bit so
let's go let's go let's get it let's get
it all the time
i've been in jewelry for years for about
15 years all right
let's go whatever store i'm in i got
friends that come and they
like oh man you know you work at that
area and then come to find out
they bought a ring somewhere else but
they bought it somewhere else and then
they come to me and say hey man what you
think about this i was like
i think you didn't buy it from me that's
what i did
[Laughter]
i mean like i think you went somewhere
else
right you want me to validate your
purchase no i ain't gonna
exactly
you just give them back the card it's
got a big giant l on it it's just like
here's your l
you fail yeah but it's you know what
happens like you
they go into like these high pressure
stores and like they get hyped up and
then they buy it and then they want me
to make them feel good about what they
did
exactly exactly that validation don't do
that to your friends people
true that yeah whatever yeah
yeah but buy buy from buy from this man
if you need an engagement right well it
wouldn't
used to but yeah you should you should
have let's just say i still have
connections
i'll get you that i'll get you that
discount how much one dollar because
everybody's paying the same thing
there's no discounts in jewelry
i'll save you the i'll save you like the
the paper registration fee
i got that i got that i'll make you feel
good i'll give you a feel good price
[Laughter]
what else we got here because i was
going to get into uh we got to talk
about that destiny
we had a crazy crazy week going on
obviously we got the preview last week
with what was coming but i don't think
anybody knew so
kind of wanted to go into the season
since we had a few days to play it
obviously we've all been putting some
time in
um but just like from when you guys like
logged in
first and since you've been playing a
little bit what is just like what was
the high level feeling on like
first day and i'm saying this for a very
specific reason you all know why
first day like first hour what'd you
guys get out of that like that first
hour
like how how'd that go for you guys any
revelations
any uh any internal thoughts there
let's go i like chicken and melon just
as much as the next person
but bunji was serving up
a lot of chicken and honeydew melon
little chicken
um but yeah it was
it was to be expected yeah uh
i i have no hot takes on that i mean
what about you it's
yeah service don't work or during the
launch
shot shot yeah bro it's so funny
you said i'm glad you said that flawless
because i literally shout out to forte
it was me forte addict
in the chat and it's like a couple hours
but imagine that couple it was the day
off
so the plan was like all right so what
we're going to do we're going to get
we'll go live at time we all going to
jump on at the same time i'm like no
we're not
i said y'all know what's going to happen
i said i said so i'm going to sleep
right and i'm going to catch y'all later
in the day
post launch i know how this go you know
what i'm saying
i was surprised only for one reason
there's only one part of it i was
surprised because generally
seasonal launchers don't tend to have
that issue as much
but you know when the new expansion come
like there's times flawless what i've
taken off work on
you know what i'm saying i'm ready and
that's that right
thank you all right and then you sitting
there with that q number
oh man and then the number goes up and
then it never goes
i'm such a destiny vet i know
do not get your hopes that high that
you're gonna play at the exact moment
they tell you what's going on
no because you know what it's gonna be
that maintenance you know it then before
that
you know you got the download then when
you get downloading this day you still
not getting in because you're gonna get
the q number you can get a blueberry
blackberry
a beetle or whatever you're gonna get so
yeah i was chilling so at the end then
you're gonna go all through the queue
you get into the game then you load it
to the top
and then the game crashes
back in the queue
[Laughter]
contact the destiny servers
we have been through this rodeo before
so i chilled i waited for all the
destruction and chaos to be over with i
woke up
early and when i logged in it was fine
for me because it was
hours past it but yeah what about you
man what was your
experience like i i know you probably
was waiting on stream
trying to get that phone so
no no like the night before so my wife
had gone to surprise her mom for
mother's day
flew up to kansas city she was trying to
come back
we had a lot of weather blowing through
monday night so the fly was supposed to
get in somewhat late
now on tuesdays i typically work early
and by early i mean i'm up at like 4 30
in the morning
so i had to get up at 4 30 but then her
flight that i was going to pick up at 10
i'm like
don't always get the most sleep on
tuesdays stuff happens it's fine
her flight got in at one oh wow it was
pushed back like three hours
i tried to get like a bit of a nap in
i'm slowly starting to fall asleep maybe
like 11 to try and get a little nap
before i pick her up
i swear it's like one of those lightning
strikes where it feels like it hits your
neighbor's house it shakes your house so
much
yeah like strobe light like bam and i'm
like
i'm up again okay so it's like it was
one of those and like gmd's in chat like
texas thunderstorms are legit so
every so often you get one of those and
you're like okay that had to be like
the pole outside just you know my front
yard had to be close it feels like it
and it's still probably not that close
anyway so i got like three hours i'm
like dragon ass in the morning
going to work do that then i'm like all
right can i just like bail early for the
meeting by the time i get word on that i
end up staying for the meeting
go through all of that finally come home
and then i'm like sitting there so i do
actually log in
and i'm like okay let's see what happens
for a bit
and i'm like honeydew honeydew just kind
of waiting for like the patch to get
done i was like
all right guys i'll see you guys in
about four hours i'm gonna go to sleep
exactly and i just went to bed
it was easy we're gonna give this just a
little bit and then i was like
nah i'll give it some sleep i'm not even
gonna set an alarm woke back
up and they were like taking down
servers went back just laid back down i
was like
yeah big nap so yeah it it was exactly
what i expected i was like yeah maybe
but i was like if it doesn't i was like
please don't work servers i almost in
the back of my mind i was like i need
some sleep
yeah because you need to sleep so yeah i
was totally fine with that
i feel you so i i had a video idea
for the launch i'll probably still use
it so i'm not going to say
we got to get that exclusive yeah i
ended up doing a different video
because of some of the other stuff that
was happening but
um you know the needless to say
the server issues at launch are very
much expected
[Music]
so next launch you know you'll know it's
like this is what he was talking about
he's like i made this video four months
ago i was ready
boy was ready yeah well you know so once
you actually
got into the game we got kind of a cool
experience
one that i don't know if i've actually
experienced in destiny except maybe kind
of closer to last season
but we got a very different experience
to start the season and when you log in
you've got your little quest to go do
and we know this season
is about misrex or mythrax i love the
way he says it though it's actually
really cool
um so we get that little cinematic with
him we do our little like
you know jump into the network and then
then after you get done with that
mission i never expected us to go where
we did
yes so who wants who wants uh when you
guys got to
finish that first mission and you were
dropped into that new little zone
do you guys go exploring like like
flawless how was that how was that
experience when you finally got to got
out of that mission
ether x was there and you're chilling
you're like where am i and then it hits
you yeah
it's like i'm in the raid um
you're like wait what the hold on am i
gonna do that
yeah it was a great experience um just
seeing all the
the new characters or not the news
characters returning characters kind of
being used in the story lakshmi
i'm you know i'm an fwc guy
good to see you and um and then
of course the from the trailer and
everything we knew that they were coming
um but to also walk around the area and
see like the fallen babies and or
the elixir babies um
it was great i love it i love everything
about this new season
so far um just from the aesthetic
um i've i've renamed it season of the
drip
oh i see that
um so i love you know i'm digging
transmog so far i haven't run into any
any of the constraints that everyone was
worried about but
uh yeah i like it so far yeah uh a good
question e i think uh
same thing like um obviously we start we
go in the cave
you know we're searching for mithrax our
core is trying to lead us
the right way you know shout out to the
new icora she's doing a good job you
know what i'm saying and um as far as
voice actress
and uh yeah then we we get right to that
location and the first thing i was like
oh this is cool we had scored you to you
know says
the fastest way in the city you know
they got a nice little outpost shout out
to the vanguard sleeping bags though
shout out to the vancouver
really take care of the fall you know
what i'm saying giving them that company
product you know
saying i was liking that but um yeah
it's a cool use of a space and then
obviously the scannables all around
you know and you what is it idle i don't
know if i'm pronouncing it correctly
yeah e-i-d-o yeah i know you're not yeah
yeah you know you're getting the
the background on them you're getting
you know fallen lore
and stuff like that which is which is
really cool so yeah i love the use of
the space
and like like flawless said it was a
pleasant surprise to see
laxmi because you know especially with
them getting rid of faction rally
and getting rid of the characters in the
actual tower you know i'm saying because
i was a new
modern i used to be a uh fwc way back
today but
um i'm a new monarchy guy and um you
know
obviously when you go to the top hideo
is not there iraq jalal's not there
actually not there they're just in this
space so it kind of was sad like damn i
missed kind of talking
to the characters so to see that they
still have the actress
and she's still there and then obviously
osiris was there to greet them and stuff
like that
and i just like i like australia's my
man but i like this whole ambassador
thing that they're doing
where it's like look it's going to take
time you know for
some people not going to be with this
you know so to speak but yeah you know
we we have to be unified friends so
what's funny to me though this is real
quick for it
is after all of that they're making it
seem like you know it's gonna be this is
our secret you guys can stay here
in this hotel here and you know and then
when i go to the tower i'm like it's
falling all over the place i'm like
yeah they're chilling they're at the
i thought they was going to be just in
the helm like like fro
i'm like yo y'all at the vending machine
too y'all y'all get real
comfortable very crazy right next to
drifter you know you're hungry
come on man you know what he'd be eating
y'all right
bro i i thought it was the funniest
thing i i was surprised to see the
abundance of
fallen that i was going to say but other
than that the start was fantastic but a
bunch
like when you first hour you just kind
of messing around like what
i mean for me yeah it's like really cool
to get that opening story mission you're
like okay cool using europa go save me
thrax ship has crashed and kind of
figure out where he's been for a little
bit
and then i was like i was like where am
i like i'm actually in the scourge of
the pass raid boss area
and then i started walking around and
seeing the scannables and listen to ida
talk about
history and she's the scribe of the
house of light and she's his daughter
i'm like
i did all the scannables and the one
that tells you she's his daughter
last i'm like oh that makes more sense i
should have listened to that one first
but like
i swear i learned more about the fallen
and elixie in like
20 minutes than i have in seven years it
was
i'm like i know there's been some
history in here but like the what we got
like
some people are hilarious saying like
okay i've been slaughtering fallen for a
long time now and i kind of feel a
little bad about it because now i've
learned more and you're like
you talk about ether and like this is
what we need to survive and you're like
captains are what we're supposed to be
if ether is like
in reasonable abundance but it's all
rationed by these people and like
doled out very little by little it's
like we're all basically like
feeble unfinished growing fallen and
we're not what we're supposed to be
because we can't get enough either so
you're like
sorry for blowing up all those ether
tanks guys i'm i'm sorry
like everyone you see you're like i'll
call them like now if i'm walking
through i'll leave that one alone yeah
my defense they usually shoot at me
first
those are not house lights but yes
that's that's true but that's kind of
the thing that's like really interesting
of
i will say though and i think um lord
cognito you talked about it on
your um ilp minute with uh joshua oh the
lord's many other lords are giving up
yeah and
the one thing that i was kind of hoping
for yeah who shot first
where's travis when you need him yeah
the only thing was we got the title
story wrap up at like week seven
and we never got anything we got we got
a little
we got a little voicemail from crow we
actually did get a little
acknowledgement there at one point
in the new server area got that one from
him i was like okay there's a little
they acknowledged that that was kind of
abrupt but like kyle's just like
hey here's the blade i'm still friends
dude like
nothing i'm like not that's the only
thing for me about like the seasons
where like the narrative connection is
like i know we want to focus on this
right now but
correct we did just like we had all this
stuff going on now we're just gonna like
park that bus we're gonna drive this one
try and catch it up
i agree and then at some point like can
some of these like travel together
that's kind of the thing that i
would like to see is a little bit of
connection like title pops into a
voicemail be like
so i see you got some elixir down there
in the tower is it going to get awkward
with the
we're going to get a little weird nausea
going on like i don't know it's like
something to just acknowledge that
you've got like
an alliance with cabal and now you've
got this alliance with fallen
and the other two like do they know
about each other you got like a
girlfriend on the side like
somehow these two need to acknowledge
each other it's just i don't know i'd
like some connection between seasons
because they do sometimes feel a bit
abrupt
bad jokes we're going to see that
connection
with witch queen when everything i think
we're going to see everything just kind
of come to a head
see with these see the payoff for these
alliances and
and whatnot that's my prediction yeah i
agree i agree i think
it's all i feel it's like he's kind of
been calling for a long time we're going
to get like this avengers style moment
where it's like you know we
we these are our feelings
captain america like a symbol line who
gets to say that is that zavala
is does he get that honor it's gotta be
it's gonna be cage six
back from the dead six is gonna be like
all right
on your left oh my god
uh
i would literally die that would be the
end of d flawless oh yeah
that would be amazing absolutely crazy
yeah
like i said all i all i want is again if
you're not going to use kato the
character
just an either an off-screen reference
or some type of law piece saying hey
she's off to do this that now we're
she's busy securing this or whatever
and we're fine but like no talk about
like the season
didn't happen i'm just like uh we had
like i mean we had the almighty event
as like this test i don't know if it was
too much work if it was like
technical like thank god that worked we
don't want to try that again we almost
broke this i don't know what like
it was so cool to set that up but it's
been so long since we've seen that since
like season of the worthy
and i'm like just a little you had the
closing ceremony of guardian games
and like everybody's like hey is
something gonna happen is there gonna be
like something with you know the
guardian game ceremony some hunter comes
in here's the new statue
what nothing nothing in relation
and it's just like the finish of this
one to the next one was cool it's like
so
it was like i love what we got but i was
like i just missed a little connection
between but yeah like fallen
all of a sudden i'm like dude these are
kind of awesome now so it's like i'm
yeah they're starting to come together
now i heard this on i forget where i
heard this
it might have been actually you guys
talk yeah i was you guys talking about
it uh
if every race at some point would be our
ally which i thought was interesting so
i wanted to ask follows as well
do you how many races that we currently
interact with do you think we might
actually have an alliance with at some
point
to face whatever we do how many outside
of these two which we seem to have
something
do you think we'll get any other races
on our side
um so there's what following cabal
hive scorn vex
i can't see us allying with allying with
any other ones other than the the two
that we have because the vex are just
like
evil robots
and however just you know they're jacked
in the scorn
they're jacked fallen
right so i think this might unless they
introduce a new race
i can't see us forming an alliance with
any of the other races so i think
it might be a thing of guardians
alongside cabal and fallen
possibly taking on whatever new threat
uh
that has either taken over the mine or
taken control of
or has also allied with the other enemy
races so
that's that's kind of where i see it
going i put a shameless plug of
my website inside oh no absolutely yeah
that's a good little channel appreciate
that shout out to john yeah
he he posed a great question you know
and i love doing that uh with him
on the site and um yeah i'm with
flawless like i just
can't see it now to josh's point he's
like well the hive view sought logic
and if we you know take out you know
whatever and we
we run it then you know they would have
to follow us okay from a technicality
standpoint yeah
and there's a power vacuum up top the
only other one theoretically up there
would be
uh ziva wrath but she's still been like
second fiddled to sabathune but if
somehow like both of those drop and
there's like
yeah a big emptiness wouldn't that even
be a shaky alliance right because
aren't they kind of like the sith they
always just like looking for just to
stab you in the backpack
yeah i don't think that i think like
lakshmi's current hesitation about the
fallen
would be much more justified if we're
like hanging out in the tower you got a
night walking through like
you know yeah they just don't look
they're like the cuddly
friendly type at the vending machine i
don't think you're gonna see it
if y'all want to chill and not be so
hostile i'm cool bro but
you know you're not going to be drinking
my drinks out this machine all right
[Laughter]
leave that machine alone especially
that's my flavor
touch that button that's mine and i wish
i feel like that
the hive verm i mean the the vex remind
me of like the get from mass effect so
it's like this
yeah you know central mind and unified
hive mind yeah
don't see it like i said unless the only
thing they can say is if there's some
outside force let's they make up some
threads of outside forces the sole
controller of the
of the vex which i don't see and you
know we still with the hive logic thing
you know we still have maura to account
for
messing around in them realms you know
we don't know what's going on with her
so
yeah i think this is going to be the
extent and it kind of makes sense
because
you know the fallen and the cabal let's
be real they're kind of
broken in a way like the houses the
cabal
infrastructure between you know gaul
already been
uh finished who knows what their
homelessness is on their home planet is
gone
and their whole planet everything's gone
so it makes sense
for those two in the state that they're
in to to kind of think but i didn't even
think about the school and i forgot
about that you know
but it is all there is they're like
falling darkness twisted crazy
yeah those don't seem to be like
conscious enough to even do anything but
try and kill us so exactly basically
zombies right yeah
basically yeah yeah
so i agree i agree i think that's today
i think this is the extent
of what we get as far as the two races
as for
one of the races vex we are do have our
new endless knight in the tower
uh this is kind of like a weird sci-fi
movie where you have to like suspend
disbelief because i'm sitting in the
tower and i'm like
all right you got nighttime i love the
particle effects in the air where you
see the little like
lines drawn a little like blue particles
you're like all right so i'm in the
matrix in this hour
but i can fly out of the matrix to the
edz and then i'm no longer in the
simulator
that's where i'm like yeah i'm like
so if i can fly outside of it can i see
what's going like
i just i don't quite understand what's
happening and i know i shouldn't dig
that deep but i'm like
come on i want to i want to get this but
if i can fly outside of it and i'm
totally fine out there
then yeah i don't know it's weird so
unless we're just all sleeping in the
matrix something
something doesn't quite fit to me so i
wondered if you guys had any cares about
that you're just like yeah it looks cool
who cares
yeah well this season does have a lot of
matrix and tron vibes so maybe it's done
purposely i don't know
yeah yeah yeah i mean you know it's one
of those things where it's just like
video games yeah you know i'm just like
video games you know say i'm going i'm
going to put this in my mind
what y'all trying to say but i hate me
video games going to video game
exactly they go video games
well for video games sake we did get a
new activity this season
and we got a uh splicer gauntlet to go
with it so we got our
we got our hammer approving 2.0 uh
we got our war table 2.0 and then we got
the new activity override so i wanted to
see what you guys think about the new
activity
the gauntlet the table if you guys are
digging the new vibe if it's a bit
grindy how you feeling how much have you
played it
what do you guys think flawless what you
got
um yeah i've i've played a good bit of
override
um i dig it i dig it um i love going
into the vex network
um it's kind of it's kind of simple
enough
you know just shoot stuff and bank modes
basically
um but it's still fun there's different
phases different bosses you
um you can go into the portal and defeat
a boss and bank the data spike i love
the boss at the end
and they're going to add different
versions of it um
um and i don't i think it's a good
length
not too long not too short um not too
complicated but also has some mechanics
to it so i think it's a
a really solid activity i love the loot
this season
um so the loot that you're able to get
from it um
has been phenomenal i think
um so yeah i've been really digging it
the
as far as the
uh the war table stuff i haven't
interacted with the war table
too much i didn't even realize that
there was anything new going on at the
war table i've just been
uh focusing engrams i do like that you
don't have to
focus the engram and then decrypt that
engram yeah oh god
that joint was java be crazy yeah yeah
yeah yeah
that was huge i was like thank you now
we can just get rahul
to accept these
[Music]
[Laughter]
it is annoying when you get a prime and
you can't do nothing with it and over
there and then
it's like yeah that's separation of of
yeah yeah
i agree i agree for sure yeah man um
yeah for me it was kind of like you know
first off off the top i'm a huge fan
of six man activity like i always hate
when you gotta break up the squad i got
a big party chat going on xbox and it's
like all right guys
you know i'm going to what you call to
go here and then we got to break fire
team up because
unless you're raiding or it's that you
know when banner's coming you're not
staying in parties at six so i love that
i keep most of my clan in the giant and
for acidic right
you know it's it's simple enough you
know the bank the
uh moat banking and stuff like that and
the orb and the little spiral thing at
the top
shoot the things the the actual part
that i like the most when you actually
go
into the network and the little like the
slip and slide
the slide yeah i like how many times
have you died on that
oh i doubt that the new jokers i like
who gonna break their legs on the phone
who go bro
so i like i like that joy it did it
almost
gives me leviathan vibes like a race
to the like who gonna get into the thing
first and then you got the little
the traps and the stuff and i don't mind
it it's like a little it's a nice
change of place with pace with
platforming you know what i'm saying
like just to go through so
you know you got the boss i'm very
curious to see how it evolves
in the other locations are there going
to be different
uh sections or mechanics with other
things stuff like that
simple enough you know fun i want to see
how much also how much harder it can get
and also like floyd said i i'm loving
the loo the loot is really strong i got
me this grenade launcher that i'm loving
it's kinetic one
oh i think it's i forgot what it but it
i got it's like bl it's
blind blind shot yeah oh man
slide shot on that sushi i i need that
roll
i need that roll i think i got mine
blinding
i think it's um frenzy for now and i'm
like wow this is good
you know i mean so i've been really
really enjoying having it it's like
because we obviously we don't have
mountaintop sidebar
interesting to see the infinity symbol
now
next to power level yeah the officially
yeah oh yeah
and it's so weird because i know i'm
going off on a tangent but it's so weird
because it's just like
they were so hardcore about the sun
setting like three months man
three months for one of the biggest
decisions they've ever done and you're
like
okay but bungie doesn't listen guys we
can't we can't praise them too much
that's true that's true we can't praise
them too much
but they do buff stasis with the new
season but we'll get to that
all they heard was stasis they didn't
hear the nerf station
yeah they got the wrong side of that
memo so yeah exactly but
override so far so good but what's your
feeling what's your feeling
you know what you played uh somebody had
a good meme so i didn't want to read it
be like oh look
we've got a bank you've got to collect
some moats
you summon a big enemy you've got an
invasion portal
we have gambit
it is basically pve gambit
which theoretically is what some people
ask for which is too funny
the moats are still a pain in the ass to
pick up so that box has been checked
they are
definitely still like you're like i got
i got it dude i'm just staying come on
come
on okay there you go i got you um
and i enjoy it it's yeah it's not bad
but i guess
as my start of the season was
first you got the currency for like
decrypted data you're like okay how do i
get this stuff so i go in here open the
chest i get 30. like all right
so then i figured out like the splicer
gauntlet upgrade so now i open it and i
get 55.
do that by the way uh yeah also do not
please
don't focus your umbrells save your
currency until that
gauntlet is upgraded yeah yeah yeah yeah
you tell them tell them tell them
tell us yeah the same video wow
i know the same currency used a focus
umbrella engram which it was fixed but
it was costing twice as much
is the same thing you used to do the
splice or gauntlet upgrade so like
that's not the best but then as you go
through the upgrades i was like okay
probably the most important one outside
of capacity doesn't even tell you the
the like kind of the most important
thing that it does the like override
efficiency so when you open the chest
it just says you're gonna get more loot
i'm like i'm gonna get so much loot this
season i don't care
so the first video i made and uploaded
was like okay go for efficiency then go
for the random ether drop so you can get
more and more
and then one of the comments overnight
was like hey override efficiency gives
you more i was like okay let me go check
you get five more then you get 15 more
and then you get 25 more every time you
open the chest so if you get down to
tier three
every time you run override you'd
basically get twice as much
so like that kind of changed what i went
for but now it's like
all i've literally been doing since it
has been strikes all week is like
three strikes four overheads three
strikes
four overrides three strikes four over
right i've been in override
a lot a lot right now there's a lot of
stuff coming in the future
there's the expunge mission which i am
looking forward to
and those are usually my favorite but
like as you start to do this a lot
it does get to be like
this is so far pretty much what we've
got
for the season so it's like well it's
like i enjoyed it at first then i was
playing it and now i've been playing it
for like three days
basically non-stop outside of doing a
lost sector farm some yesterday
it's it's a bit much um to do that many
times over and over so it's like that's
kind of one of the points where
as we just got europa even maybe another
planet and another boss like somewhere
in there and i know they spaced them out
over weeks but
yeah if you burn through this week in
your gauntlet i might play the other two
planets like
twice and be out if i knock everything
out this week so it's kind of one of
those where it's like a little variety
up front would be nice to see
i feel yeah i mean like i said when you
you're also running
you know what i call like you know
utmost efficiency
you know what i mean so oh i know it's
like and the streamers and the person
who logs on for like two hours and it's
like hey
couple okay i got my ether stored up
when i get back on tomorrow i'm gonna go
run over it a couple times for that
person
it's probably actually not a bad loop
because it is not nearly as bad
as the hammer like they were usually it
takes like six months for them to
learn and they've even said that it's
like the seasons are in development they
can only change so much but this time at
least like
you can grind the splice or gauntlet
indefinitely
you could literally knock it all out
this week so there's not a time gate of
like two serious little challenges
nothing else they are they're a bonus in
there which is nice so it's like
if you don't grind hard you'll actually
probably have a better
feel about that activity because as you
go through seasonal challenges you're
going to get 150 here 250 later on in
the season stuff like that
like we did before i'm sure right um and
you'll unlock it slowly over weeks
right so i got you for that average
person sure
for me just sitting there like trying to
work on the new thing there's not a lot
of options to do it so that's all it's
like i wish
i don't know i was like i just can't if
you do want to grind hard there's really
one thing that you're working on to
start right now
so i'll figure i mean you could get
yourself in those uh law sector sir if
you would
really well a challenge if you really
want to spice things up and get some of
those uh that juicy loot there i did get
my new legs thank you
oh boy he's already in there okay
i haven't done that yet i haven't you
can run that together well it's gonna
switch over here in a couple hours but
you can run that thing in about well i
think my best one was like three and a
half minutes
well it was like nice fire was like
solar was the burn
and then the only enemy who had a shield
was the boss and it was arc
so xenophage if you got igneous hammer
you could use that just to pop some
heads
and then when you get to the boss after
the two champions are dead just
literally i could go um curious of the
fallen star smash it and grab the chest
and go
so yeah you can do it in about three and
a half minutes so yeah 323 that was the
one i did yesterday so
nice nice so so i gotta get it there man
the one thing
honestly like the other thing is i keep
trying to get a pulse rifle
from override i can't get one and that's
the one weapon like
that's already made of video
helmets and stuff that looks like
somebody shoved a shank on my head but i
can't get one pulse rifle
and that's my thing i want my pulse from
grid skipper yeah
uh i mean the auto rifle feels pretty
good i got one of those with um
kind of like kill clip and then it's
something up
heat no is it heating up yeah heating up
yep
yeah so like if you get a kill and then
like you'll get the extra damage and
then if you reload
after a kill you'll get like increased
efficiency and more vertical recoil
whatever it's like but yeah if i get
killed man that thing feels like a laser
beam and it feels pretty solid too like
i haven't taken it into pvp yet but it
feels pretty good but
yeah i'm dying for that pulse rifle i'm
glad to see a kinetic grenade launcher
yes love it man if you guys said slide
shot on there like i haven't had that
one yet but
there's there's some fun perk
combinations in there this season i
think what do you guys got any standout
loot so far i know i rambled there for a
bit
no no you're good you're good photos or
any other ones that are for you that
have really hit hard for you
that you like lukewarm loot wise
um so loot wise i have been
i like the new perk heating up it's
really cool so i just got an auto rifle
uh the other day it has heating up and
kill clips pretty good
um i just unlocked the yeah it's sick um
i just unlocked the uh the null
composure
um kind of underwhelming in pvp but it's
it's pretty powerful in pve um
i like the new shotgun you can roll
quick draw it's a it's a slug shotgun
yeah okay i got one i wrote i wrote
quick draw surrounded on it
is it kinetic energy what is it what is
it uh
i also got rapid hit on it which is nice
you know
which is nice so there's definitely some
strong loot
uh i just got the uh the machine gun i
don't have the pulse rifle so i i'm with
the ibotta song okay somebody else man i
feel like everybody else has that damn
weapon and i'm like
i've gone i've grinded over it a lot and
opened that chest and every time it's
like armor i'm like you son of a
like i barely get guns out of there i've
just got so much armor
so no i'm dying for one i don't care
what it is and the grenade launcher man
i got slide shot one for all on this
grenade launcher
you shoot it into a crowd of enemies
you got one for all up and running slide
oh it's just
combinations yet that's that sounds
spicy i got us a joiner sale that i
tweeted out because i was like this
seems cause that's the new shotgun
i got an opening shot quick draw
accurized rounds
hammer forged rifling with a range
master work on it so if i yeah
that went up yeah it would have like 93
range on it if i wanted it to so
yeah i was like and i suck with slug
shotguns but
apparently i probably need to try and
get better because if i'm going to that
one seems like it would be the way to go
so we'll see if i actually put some work
in on that one but
yeah there's some interest i love the
aesthetic of all of them though like
yeah
every one of the new weapons the shotgun
the machine gun the auto rifle even the
little sidearm
while it may feel like it's shooting
peanuts like it still looks good
the like animations the sound effects on
these i'm digging the whole
seasonal weapon set for sure like they
all
feel good cool mix combinations they've
been pretty fun so far
i can't front when i was um using the
exotic quest for the um
what you call it the uh [ __ ] and it's
that quality
the anesthesia right whatever
i was liking it right i was putting it
working crucible because it forced me to
go in there because you know they want
you to get like the um
yeah whatever it is and um yeah like
there's only one nitpick i have it i got
it i'm just trying to know what the
catalyst does okay so
killing somebody what is that headless
makes it crazy i don't know what it does
i
need to know what the catalyst do
because here's my main beef with it for
the side
i get the kills yeah i get the kills so
i got my
my shot ready i got my stasis shot i'm
like who what who getting froze
who getting froze right so then i shoot
them
and they fro that mine only got like 13
in the clip so let's say you took about
six
to kill somebody right then you shoot
the charge up shot
so now you probably got like two or so
left and then i'm trying to kill and the
froze
the freeze does not last that long it
may be like you're missing a switch
it's like a switch right that's what it
is so you don't think you're gonna kill
with the the cryostesia with you better
switch to something
else because the time i was like oh yeah
i got you ah
oh damn reload reload and then they
killing me and i'm like no that's not
good
it's supposed to go i froze you
that's not how this is supposed to go i
wanted to be
toxic and i was like damn like they shot
me there so now i'm like all right
i gotta have another you know what i'm
saying with it i want it to be toxic
wow yeah i kind of wanted to i wanted a
really
it's a good gun man i'm telling you it's
really good like getting kills is a
non-issue
with that archetype for me you know i'm
saying at least the way i play with
backing up from apes or
even being aggressive in mid-range
situations it's really good so
yeah it's like something with that
weapon like the reload feels long
especially like i was even using it
wrong at first and then i was like
take the shots i thought after we
watched the preview like i had to reload
to like be able to use the extra
you could have one bullet left and it's
just gonna use the rest of your clip
when you use the frozen shot i was like
all right
this makes a little more sense now but
also in pvp it's like you get one kill
and you got 10 seconds to freeze
somebody i was like
that's gonna be a little spicy i have
not jumped into pvp yet so that's
we'll get to that discussion um okay
yeah all right no no like what do you
think
you have like i'm out of curiosity it
hasn't been an issue for me in pvp if
anything i've just been fresh kind of
like what you were saying
uh lord cognito i was just um
it's frustrating to get the kill and
then to realize
that you can't use that gun so you
either need to
if you're on hunter you need a dodge or
you need to have a a weapon that you can
swap to
but usually if you're using a shotgun
why didn't you just kill them with the
shotgun if you want to slide on range
that's what i'm saying
it forces me to run shotgun and it's
just weird now i have no long-range
capability
right and that's why i don't like
playing that way but hold on
to save the blade he said the catalyst
if you shatter the target
the gun reloads all right so they want
the synergy there but
i'm with you flawless that that part
about it i'm like
but you still have to shatter the target
right yeah yeah you need something else
to kill
to kill the guy you just froze so yeah
as to cross using like
basically switching to say salvagers or
something like that
shoot the frozen target switch back and
now he's reloaded so he's just cycling
back and forth he's like all right guys
yeah i've gone over to the dark side i'm
sorry but this is it now
but the problem is again it forces a
very close
range play style and if you're playing
you know
a mid to long range maps you're not
killing nobody that far out with that
sidearm so
that's my only thing because i'm more of
a pulse you know kind of guy so i'm
sorry
yeah no in pvp you're a message
i am sorry i have to give you a hard
time
i loved my go figure and i got called
out for using that thing for
so long and then all of a sudden he's
like i'm a pulse rifle guy i'm like
excuse
me he tried to slip that one in he's
like
i've argued with this bed that i've like
pulsed like he was what i remember when
600 was lit
right and he's like yeah i like it like
this and i'm like i
feel that they should be good but never
better than posters because i feel pulse
is more of a skill weapon
as opposed to ah 600.
so my pig is you don't like to spray and
play huh now the
difference between v-e is e will be
pulse 1 000 in every activity
seven days of the week and i'm like boy
will you try
some other guns because there's some
flying guns out here
that's the difference i like posters he
loved folks
that's the difference but i i got to
clarify a little a little bit like
anyway just not going to forget that one
but that's totally fine
um he's gonna cut out the sample and
he's gonna be like
he's like i'm a boss guy the audio must
have cut out here we moved on
he let me have that man i just repeats
over over and over like eight times
cognitive meal i'm a pulse guy
[Laughter]
i'm gonna need you to edit thank you all
right we'll talk later yeah i got you i
got you man
i'll take the criticism i'll take the
kisses
but messenger bro like i i can't get
that like desperado
and man i can't get that in pvp that's
what i'm rocking bro
that's what i'm rocking what what's your
role on your messenger
um i think it's desperado unfortunately
i wasn't able to get the the classic
outlaw desperado
but i think i got like desperado and um
i'm looking at it right now his damn his
damn it's desperate
and moving target which actually from
long ranges man
you know i i'm i'm popping them heads
off man so i'm really liking it
and i think i believe you have range
master work on it so uh yeah i love
that thing like it's so funny because
desperado gives me this fake confidence
like this i'm i'm like
extra aggressive like i'm like yeah who
who wanted that who's gonna kill
everything yeah like you get passed when
you get desperado
desperado
i'm like okay wait a minute i didn't
have any health enough health to
challenge i should have waited
you know yeah yeah i don't need help i
got this yeah
yo i get too cocky i get way too cocky
with i gotta same
so what i do is is i get cocky but also
whenever i get a kill and i know it was
because of desperado i always sing
desperado
oh man he's with some pipes to go with
the comedy this man's a triple threat
over here
it feels so good
[Laughter]
this man about to give us a solo just
dropping dropping a new
new track right here on the podcast you
know you know
i dabble sounds pretty good on my end
it's better than anything i got coming
out of this voice box so you won't do it
dude so i do want to jump in
obviously we got new aspects for stasis
and
that seems to have caused a bit of
a kerfuffle in the community overnight
and
some insanely long twitter threads um
yeah both the two big ones that i saw
were fairly like
calm but collected um yeah there's
there's a bit of movement going on right
now tas even threw a video up there just
flat out
you know
if you play pvp if you support this if
you feel like it's the right thing
if you feel like people just need to
like deal with it do you think
do you think and it is nerve stasis
we'll say it in chat do you guys think
this has
any justification at this point
do you think it's a bit overblown or
what do you feel
let's go flawless this is it it's all
humans uh
nerve stasis um i agree
with nerve stasis in pvp
okay um i was talking i was talking
about this with chat a little bit
yesterday when we started stream
stasis in pve if destiny was a pve only
game stasis would be no
problem it's fine it's great i love it
pvp the worst thing you can do to a
guardian
is is stop them and the second worst
thing you can do to a guardian is slow
them
and stasis gives you both of those in
abundance
just for having your normal abilities so
like if you're if i'm in a super
and you're a warlock and you have your
melee guess what you get to stop me in
my tracks
um so it needs to be nerfed it's way too
hot it's way
it's up too much um but i
whatever change they do i only want them
to do it
in pvp um and
you know so one idea that i had is
just take everything that freezes and
make it slow
and make the slow very short because if
you if you're slowed for one second
you're at an extreme disadvantage and it
also should
absolutely not suppress you it should
not take away your aim it should not do
all the other stuff that it does so
it's just like you know i think rick
hack has made a video about it
um a while back and he's like you know
and then what if it suppresses you
and then what if it takes your aim away
if it does this
i'm like bruh just pick a thing i would
almost like to see the freeze and slow
taken
out of it in pvp and just like those
grenades just do flat damage
uh you know it if for the cold snap for
example it tracks you and it just does a
certain amount of damage
yeah um that would be fine
supers freezing okay it's a super it
should be powerful but the neutral game
stuff
it's just too much it's too oppressive
so i i i agree with
the nerf stasis in pvp
in pvp yeah i'm with i i'm gonna push
back a little over just maybe one thing
but
before i comment e what is the general
consensus before because i've missed the
actual
dialogue in the community so what was
like the community saying before i
comment because i want to be i want to
be correct
first off why i mean talk from what i've
gathered
is the main idea behind
destiny's higher skill level especially
in pvp
a lot of it comes from movement so much
of a high skill level in pvp comes from
movement you take people
like me who are on a very casual like
1.02 kd
like i'm just average not gonna claim a
lot of skill
and my lack of skill i'm okay at a shot
i have decent moments where i hit some
shots definitely could work on that as
well
but my movement probably sucks in
comparison to somebody at a high level
much less you know game awareness or
anything else because i've watched a
couple of
nomad videos but uh he's a beast shout
out to nomad yeah
he had a long thread and the idea is you
know old i saw that one that was a good
thread yeah okay
it takes one of the reasons high skill
level is such a thing
is because it that allows the skill
ceiling to be so much higher
right and then it also the idea is if
you have your abilities up that could
basically stop
anything including a super in their
tracks you also have a somewhat easy
button
so it brings the skill floor up a lot
higher than the ceiling down
so then the idea of like how good can
you get at this game you're like well i
can tell you to get good but if somebody
freezes you
yeah you know nothing you can do about
it there's no like hey you could always
dodge back try and get into a better
position try and recover your health
you could have played a better position
if you mean somebody and then just
freeze and you're like
what can you do or you can bounce a
double kunai around the corner i gotcha
then you're truly screwed because you
can't like
there are things in this subclass and as
you said the neutral game which i'm
still
almost kind of learning what that means
but i kind of get like the idea of what
this subclass can do
so frequently and depending on if it's
like dodges to get your
like kunai back or whatever it may be
it's so often that
if you play any other subclass and they
just took away the one main one
and that's the other piece that just was
seemed to have been like the straw on
the camel's back
because top tree dawn blades movement is
insane
right and mostly as a titan believe me
i'm like well i can't move like that
that's insane
that's i feel glued to the ground over
here but also on the other side
that was a decent counter to stasis yes
because they could dash out of being
frozen and that just got nerfed too so
everybody's like
okay so you're gonna glue us to the
ground and if you aren't running stasis
you truly are
basically shooting yourself in the foot
to start the match so
that's i got the contest that's kind of
if that summed it up pretty well
flawless you got to tell me if i was
off base or not but yeah no i agree
i agree the nutri game should not be as
powerful
for one subclass as it is right
no i hear what you guys are saying and i
mean look obviously i got my stacy's
shirt on so i do have a love for the
for the fun yes man
how's that money truck from bungie doing
yeah shout out i know
you know that's it get away from my
promotional joint well um no
look all jokes aside i i do hear what
you're saying um
first of all i do love the class in pve
it's one of my favorite it's actually
hard for me to take it off in pve i have
so many fun builds with it as a warlock
but um in pvp i guess to nomads point
the the part do i agree with him is that
there is no effective
counter to it right that's the main
thing and then
look i don't i play pvp a lot i don't go
that crazy about it to be honest to be
brutally honest i'm not the one raging
crazily
i only i guess if i'm frozen in my super
i'm like all right
you know that's i feel very oppressive
you know what i'm saying like i'm i'm in
my super
coming to get you and you froze me with
a warlock melee or whatever it is
a quick thing that ain't feel good i
mean i shouldn't take long to break out
so i agree with that
i think the issue still with stasis is
that
the ability spam i think that to me is
the moisture like there's so many things
to kind of
either get you up time up very quickly
and get these abilities back
so quickly thus you're seeing it more
frequently and yeah they're gonna have
to do something with it now i thought it
was interesting that they made titan
boots
to have stasis resistance power those
are
also broken yes really tell everybody
real quick besides
apparently if you get tagged by stasis
and you have like enough ticks that you
kind of get that stasis
you get increased damage you
or depending on how it procs and stuff
like that basically people are two
tapping with 120s
if they get procked by stasis wearing
those boots and it's just all of a
sudden
it's going to be yeah it's going to be a
wall of titans with those boots on
going against the wall of like hunters
with all the grenade fun spam and it's
like i don't know who's going to win
that battle but it's going to be a giant
message imagine if you get that buff and
you have rampage so you're all ready to
tap it and now you got rampage up so now
you
i mean you could probably buy somebody
like yeah you're probably two body at
that point yeah yeah
i think the issue like i said they just
need
counters and i i think e me you my my
suggestion is like
i feel that that is a half as like a
half measure with the with the boots
with the titan boots right
to me me you've talked about this
like lore wise and dramatically i feel
solar subclasses should be the
antithesis of stasis
right so to me those should have
intrinsic abilities
that just naturally or or a thing that
you can change or add on
that will give you either counters
whether it be movement based or just
natural resistance
to it because that's the thing they just
need a little bit better
counters to it you know what i mean but
i said we'll see the funny thing about
it is
as much as we could play bungie's like
yo so we gonna hit y'all with these new
fragments right
and then you're gonna do this and then
you're gonna i'm just then they had like
we're gonna hit you with this new
artifact so every kill you get you get
more super energy back
with the glacial inheritance so i'm just
like
i don't know what's going on in the
boardroom where they are just like
no this is here to stay and you go deal
it's like it's like watching my man
flawless
like he
trolling like the community is irate
with this thing which i
that's why i i think it's funny and i
support it because it's just the funny
thing they refuse to listen to the
community
with this particular balancing and this
particular matter
i think it's hilarious bro
just real quick in bungie's defense
defense
because i've i am very much nerve stasis
i don't like it in pvp
if they i don't think they should and
i'm not advocating this but if they
disabled it today i wouldn't be upset in
pvp
um but you
this this giant barrel
they started rolling it downhill so all
the fragments and all the aspects you
gotta
imagine they've been made already yes
they they've been made
they were probably made months if not
years ago
and to suddenly just say all right and
we're not going to release this
you're kind of asking a lot so
yeah it's it seems tone deaf with the
timing because stasis is at its all-time
high of being a problem but at the same
time it's like all right
they've been planning this season for
how long it's gonna come out they gotta
they gotta fix it after the fact so
that's that's all i wanted to say
no you're right you're absolutely right
especially with development cycle
because what we've learned is
you know they've been like two seasons
like working on one season ahead
so before they can implement a change in
a while i to me i think
it's never gonna be in a place people
are gonna like like it
it's not going away so to me like i said
i'm
with e we talked about it i feel the
other the light subclasses need a rework
to be able to have options and abilities
that will be natural counters to stasis
on some level
and i think then you'll have less of the
you know the aggression towards it in
pvp in pve
it is fun as hell i really truly do like
it you know so
do you want to see like a a more
rock paper scissors type gamepl and we
do know
that they are eventually going to rework
the light subclasses
in the aspect and fragment sense of
how stasis is now they've already kind
of hinted the long-term goal
is to get it in there the only thing is
each you know
subclass of void solar and arc
you know they're gonna have to make
tough decisions because you know some
stuff they've already said it like some
stuff is gonna go away and that's gonna
piss
some people off but in order to get into
that style that stasis is where we have
the customization and stuff
you know we're going to have to do with
that sacrifice as long as they give us
again natural counters and then
i think hopefully that should you know
ease some of the the pain that a lot of
us are going through right now
for me as long as pvp is gun
gun play movement and positioning
focused
you know you can you know you can nerf
everything uh i forget
well it's a common sentiment is that
ability should supplement
the gun play so if i catch you out of
position
and i can make you know and i can use
whatever ability
and it makes my gun play more effective
i feel like that's the sweet spot where
instead of uh i use the ability
to compensate for my lack of gun skill
and that's what stacey said
okay you're right you're right you're
absolutely right
good point fantastic point yeah it's
like it's
it's weird to watch as you said you know
things are in development time they're
like hey these will be kind of cool and
fun
but somewhere like if you're like hey
let's make this
dustfield grenade do more have a little
crystal you can break to freeze them in
the middle
let's make this cold snap harder to
dodge
tag more p like it's it's kind of insane
to see
some of the things that that that new
hunter fragment can do
when you're just like how how
how can you like everybody's just like
oh it seems a bit strong right now and
somebody in testing is like
well this seems gonna basically come out
like a giant fart
this whole season's gonna come like a
big fart because somebody's over there
like
punters are gonna be real strong you
know that whole like silence and squall
we brought it down a little bit that is
not gonna do a damn thing when you get
your hand on these new grenades
what i'm sorry i don't quite understand
what you're saying i don't think you're
ready
nope i definitely was not like somehow
it's just so crazy to me to watch all
this like i haven't touched pvp this
season like i literally haven't jumped
in because i've just been kind of grind
out the other but just
watching this like chaos on the twitter
fire
just every time i scroll i'm like it's
just like
oh my god it's just a trash fire after
trash fire yeah
and it's like there are some very good
thought out threads like if you go like
what do people want out of this game
and like what are they looking for and
then just like this was like the icing
on top i'm like
this i think it was honestly between the
grenades breaking
like everybody and then you've got this
little lance for titans which doesn't
seem to be doing too much
and then uh what's the warlock fragment
do or the new aspect what's the warlock
aspect
oh it's the buffing lumina noble
kind of type stuff i remember yeah
apparently that's really good yeah i've
heard that's actually kind of
interesting
shout out to nem he's got a great video
like uh
a little clip on twitter about it i'm
like yeah i got to get in that legends
and get that going man that that thing
looks nice but i don't
i don't know what the stasis abilities
for the warlock are are yet i'm still
working on the umbrella stuff
and strike so i don't i don't know what
they what new stuff they have because
right now
i think the bleak watch of the turret is
still disabled
so i don't know what to do that pissed
everybody off but day and day like
you're not getting that back
you know i'm like damn i used to like
that turret but it is one of them
it's like when you look at the seasonal
map i think that's the thing
you already had a pvp community that's
like hey it's been
because even don i think somebody said
we got rusted lance so we got like one
map but it's still been officially like
it's two years since we've got a map
modes haven't changed we lost stuff in
beyond light
now you got people unhappy with the way
stasis feels at a high level because
you're getting frozen and killing high
skills with movement
and then all of a sudden you're like you
the only they don't mention like
any and that's i think the thing we've
talked about before too cognito is the
fact that like at some point they just
need to be like
they have to like address the elephant
in the room because the silence
continues to be deafening over
here's more stasis and we're doing
nothing else with pvp have fun
and good luck and it's just like you got
a community that's already on edge
wishing for anything
give them one map one map and you can't
get that in so long and it's like
at that and then when you do something
like this you're like yeah you got to
expect things to explode a little bit
so yeah it's just got to be weird to
watch
or even to your point just a tweet hey
guys
we know you want maps we're working on
it like anything
there's no information other than we
know this is what you want we're working
on it
you know and that's what these games
gotta do a better job of you know i've
been
say you know sidenote i've been going in
a little brief war with outriders
because of my whole issue initially
not being able to log into the game post
a restoration patch and
you know again we're not developers i'm
never gonna disrespect a developer
and say yo you know what's going on with
this all you gotta do
is i i'm not that guy you know what i
said but at the end of the day the key
is acknowledgement the same thing with
bungie now like
this is literally like what is it two
years you said he says we got a map yeah
you know all these you know neglected
pvp focus activities or just
rewards and structure and it's just like
you have to acknowledge
if you don't acknowledge and then again
the the optics
look bad when yao you're offering
all these stasis
buffs and and perks and all this and
people are raging
just say like flora said just say uh
literally a tweet
literally one sentence into 12. we pvp
means we see you we feel you
we've got something for you in due time
or
the next 12 or the next you know expect
something you got to set the expectation
if you don't acknowledge
and you keep putting your head down in
the sand that's when you're going to get
the irate people because people just
they assume the worst they're just yeah
you're going to get the tiki torches and
people are going to be upset
so what's even bad about it e
is even with the transmog and everybody
flipped out we haven't even got
there yet yep
i'm gonna put it but at least at the
minimum we saw the dmg tweet say
yo we see y'all we can't do nothing
right now
but i know i know i know
but at least we got that pvp and get
that in two years like
what's going on what's going on like the
to add icing on to this just nasty turd
cake you've got
yeah the rumor of the other
pvp-focused ipa yeah so then
like as you said like flawless like then
the speculation is like well hey are
they really not going to work
are they never going to touch it because
now they're over here like now you just
jump even farther like
if they could as like you guys could say
you know if they were like hey if you
guys can get through this year for us
beyond light was a tough year witch
queen we've got
we've got a whole rework planned for you
guys just just hang with us till the end
tough bro yeah exactly like iron banner
trials like comp
it's all coming so far i was like
like six million brownie points by just
saying it's coming here but now granted
the other side
if witch queen drops and pvp is still
the same a year i swear you're just
gonna like
have people like hey this expansion was
great pvp's out done
like yeah at some point it has to happen
or you have to say
we are going to pvp is a band-aid for
this other
they have to do one or the other or
just be honest and say we have no plans
for pvp at this time
our focus sat is sadly going to be here
we here where you go
set realistic expectation you know what
i'm saying
because like flawless said when you
don't say nothing you gonna make us
think the worst you're gonna make us say
oh they don't care about this
all the money's over there they don't
care about this all the money's in trash
bomb they don't care about this
like you don't make us speculate you've
got the information
it's up to you to at least disseminate
it and give realistic
expectation and timeline so you be like
okay
this may be coming here or hey we gotta
chill it's gonna be a while
once at least eric you know what we're
about two seasons away
it's coming you know what i'm saying so
this way we're gonna stop bothering you
and stop asking you i was like that's
all we got to do
100 agree on that one one thing i'll say
we're having at least discussions like
hey we'd like to know what's coming
we'd love to know aries shout out to him
and chad he said it
leave the devs alone oh yeah beat up
devs stupid like guys it is a video if
you're that often
quit the game take a break
xbox box find a new hobby
i don't know what you're going to do for
you if you feel the need to threaten
people because your game isn't the way
you want it to be you're like
find something new to do that's a big
one
because yeah between constructive
because criticism and attacking adapt
yeah like we're never going to do that
like
we are pro developer the amount of skill
and knowledge these guys
guys have in their fingers we we can't
even process ourselves
so we we're definitely not going to do
that so i agree but there's a way to be
constructive
oh yeah no it's like there's a reason
you're so passionate
about this to the point that you want to
say these things that you shouldn't say
it's because the game is good
it's a good game there's just some
things that irritate us sorry about that
i mean
absolutely that's that's the big thing
it's like it is we've been we started a
podcast in one of the like
lowest moments of curse of osiris
you know why we're doing this but we got
something to talk about at least
it's dead let's go yeah so but it is the
thing ideas like we've had the passion
for the game for years we've all been
playing it you know for forever now so
and we're still here like we want this
game to be good we always see the
potential behind it
and that's it like you can have
constructive criticism and be like hey i
wish the game was this way
this season doesn't seem to be
implemented correctly something seems
wrong this doesn't seem great
if you ever go after somebody personally
an attacker you have twitter
dms anything of that nature stop leave
get off
i don't care but that is not acceptable
so if
like that is not the way to do it
because honestly for one
you're not helping the process you're
not letting them know like hey this is
wrong
wrong because of this you're threatening
someone personally which is in no
relation to what you're doing
and the other thing it's just wrong to
do so it's like i just want to call that
out because eric said it and it's like
and you see that stuff happen every so
often believe me people with like
i'm incognito with outriders as well
dude has not been able to play the
campaign yet
had his inventory wiped was not able to
log in and
honestly it's just wrong like and that's
one of those things for
me i had a decent experience his was
utter trash
and unfortunately that's one but you
have not seen him do anything but like
he's asked he's been vocal about it and
he's like come on guys it's like can i
please get
can can we have some knowledge here was
the acknowledgement yeah that's it like
i'm literally not even demanding the fix
i'm not threatening no one i'm not
saying
i'm taking this screenshot i'm taking a
small shot i'm taking my video i'm like
look this is where i'm at
i did say though you know after a month
of me not being a play able to play a
game that i purchased this is
unacceptable
you know so i did say that but in in in
response to the devs i'm just saying hey
could you at least
let us know because there's other people
like me who are suffering post
restoration
so they they can't even play the game
like that's a next level so
just acknowledge that the issue exists
which they did shout out to them did
finally this week they did
they said we're realizing there's some
type of new authentication issue that
may have been caused
after it great then they've set
realistic expectation e this week i get
them again credit again
they go um we did some back end fixtures
on the server side
i was able so i did like five login
tests i was able to log in two out of
the five times right the other three it
just didn't work
but i don't need for me to rage because
in the second the subsequent tweet they
go
hey we are going to address another
patch
next week hopefully to try to really
hone in on that issue
see when you do that then i'm a chill i
know it's being worked on
it's gonna but the month prior i had to
get them
yeah because i was like bro y'all not
even talking about my issue and i keep
adding i don't know what else to do so
straight yeah i agree it's just
it's a way that us as a community can
communicate better
and and them as developers can be
transparent
yeah and that's like i think that's what
the community wants at this point for
pvp is
they gotta talk about it because the
elephant in the room is growing bigger
the silence is deafening whatever little
cliche phrase you want to say but it is
one of those that's just like
it's getting to be an issue and then the
more and more
you may say be like yeah they're the
vocal minority but there's enough people
that follow enough creators
and if enough of them start saying like
i can't stand the pvp i'm gonna go play
apex i'm gonna do
and you're like you can go play apex and
have fun but it's like if bungie wants
to at least
try to preserve even just saying like as
you said
gonna be a while but we got some big
stuff it's just taking a while to put
together and we don't want to half-ass
roll it out
that's fine but again it just takes some
type of discussion about it so
yeah the whole nerf stasis combined with
the lack of discussion it's a very weird
place for
what is half of this game to be right
now so it is just kind of an odd place
for
everything absolutely that being said a
whole another spicy topic transmog
season at a drip
so i baby to see if you guys can uncle
flawless out
i want to see if you guys have a job
walks off screen gets back on what's up
but for you guys how has transmog been
going have you been grinding it have you
been messing around with sets did you
spend all your currency what's up you
act
caesar to drip were you wet flawless um
i my experience with transmog has been
purely positive
um because what i thought would happen
happened
there were a few things that i wanted to
change the the game
gave me a certain allotment of of stuff
just for
logging in i think i may have purchased
three pieces out of all the things to
kind of complete my look
all the shaders are there the new
appearance system is is
is fantastic it's really great bungie
nailed it like i can't imagine how they
could have done better on the appearance
system
um where you just get to see everything
you can apply your shaders
you know see your whole look before you
go out um
so i have zero issue with trans i'm not
gonna say zero
i i do understand the community's issue
with the cap
because because of the time frame i
think the
uh the research or whatever it was
showed that
you know you get rewarded materials
every two minutes or something like that
so it's time gated basically
yeah designed to draw you to the
eververse
which is understandable you're running a
business you want people to spend money
but get rid of the cap the
eververse should be there uh for
people who want to skip that grind not
because they
have to buy it um but other than that
it's fine i i i have plenty of
trans uh synthwave that i can use if i
want to
but my uh teresa's looking good teresa's
my hunter by the way wow
theresa's looking good she's she's
dripped out she's what i'm drinking pop
wave
is the best shader in the game don't add
me
what's the name once they back give it
give me that [ __ ] wave let me know
i can't tell you what i'm going to say
i'm going to steal some swag
check it out check it out i have i have
a tweet out
um and that you can see it i don't know
if you uh
saw it but okay it's just oh
yeah okay i want in the morning get it
girl
season of the drip let's go yeah season
it a drip baby
yeah transmog is going down exactly how
i thought it was
you don't see anybody complaining about
it like how they did when they announced
it
right you know which you know they just
it was just a knee-jerk reaction from
the community
understandable the you know the cap
shouldn't be there but
it's not as bad as what people were
saying it was going to be
not fair enough i mean i mean you [ __ ]
yeah me me and floyla share a lot of the
same points i mean
you know i jumped in you know you start
to stop i will say
you know doing a quest for that if
anything is kind of
funny to me i was like all right we
gotta get the quest to get the clothes
okay cool cool we're gonna do the quest
for the clothes all right fine
but once i got into the system and you
know you shout
shout out to aydah with the she got her
little secret stuff going on she got the
little loom going on i thought that was
funny
i was like black armory weapons to swag
the swag i'm just like okay this is you
you you you pacifist now you want to do
this okay cool but um
you know i did that i will say
um what was cool for me is that
what it really hit was that um i i did
the transmog
and i always one of my favorite chests
was the um
squadron of the pass armor and i was
like oh
i saw it when i started looking at the
stuff that was like so i started to see
a lot of it and i only had the chest but
what was interesting is
while i was playing i forgot just in the
normal gameplay
i'm starting to see the other pieces
that i never acquired
drop like the headpiece the leg p to the
right stuff
and things like that as options to then
unlock later
so i thought that was cool also shaders
that i never got
i started to see through natural
gameplay unlock and i'm like okay
cool so yeah i did like maybe you know
one little outfit
i didn't get too crazy just change like
the chest change the boots stuff like
that
but the system is cool because you get
that nice preview of seeing how
things are going to be and um yeah i
mean
for the grind i'll be honest i'm
probably going to be the dude that's
going to run that the
test i like when if i really want to
look and i really
don't want to wait and i really don't
want to grind i'm probably going to do
that and i know that's the way it
designed but
at the end of the day it's one of those
things here that i feel
you know big picture that the boardroom
did win out
it is a business you know what i said
and they probably said to themselves
like look
you you won't you want to um you know
open up a publishing branch you want to
make two new ips you want to
you want to do all this then this is
what we gonna monetize
because they you know they're on their
own and i i think i don't think this is
changing for the community that is still
upset about it i do agree the cap needs
to be increased
but i don't see this i feel the
boardroom has put their foot down
and the development team is gonna have
to say look community this is what it is
and maybe six months down the road or a
year down the road
there may be some type of slight
alterations but
they have made it their business though
you're gonna monetize this
and that's just how it is you know i'm
not it's cosmetic so i'm not going to go
too crazy but i think that's where it is
but what's your um
what's your feeling about this have you
you guys are less than some of the
people out there so i'm going to have to
be the other side of the coin
just to have the discussion let's get it
let's get it
if nothing else somebody's gotta say it
on the podcast so
pitchforks and you know bonfires and
everything else out there
um so for me i
haven't really touched it that much uh i
will say the system for
your appearance of what you already have
unlocked i really like it i actually
really do
because apply to all
why it's still like that alone worth it
going through looking through it they're
like oh well it's too many pages we
don't overwhelm
they can never say that again because so
one thing people have been saying can i
get like a
favorites of shaders to like move some
of those to the front so you're not
scrolling through like yeah
you should be able to have a 48 grid
you're like how much i should say
the other day i didn't ask for a
favorite that's one thing i've seen for
a favorite so there's a little
constructive criticism but overall like
you know picking your appearance and
seeing what everything's looks like and
going through your ornaments
not too bad the issue itself is after
you get your tin
that'll be the question for you guys
when it finally comes around to it is
when you get your 10 first and you're
like hey if somebody who really likes
toying around be like all right i wanted
the full
you know i got my raid sets i got
everything i've been going through all
these things and i want to unlock like
four or five sets and
maybe i got a couple different looks i
like to bounce around between me uh
my guy looks homeless half the time
anyway because leveling up is
mostly like well i'm like i don't i'm
not gonna like change the look that
often
mostly because i'm just leveling up so
like whatever's there until i finally
settle in has been a thing like
when beyond light i at least looked like
that was covered in ice so i kind of
stuck that look for a little while so i
had some moments but
half the time i look homeless when i'm
leveling that's not as much of an issue
now but
the issue lies with and tassie's got an
article there's multiple people
is the time to get
scent strand is literally time gated
time
yeah people have tested that to get a
sense strand it takes two minutes of
killing
two minutes of like combat basically and
then every two minutes you
can get one to drop so they tested like
thrallway farming and no matter what
they did it was
about two minutes per yeah so it would
take and that's for one cent strand
and then you've got a 150 cent strand
for a single bounty and then that bounty
is gonna take you a while to do as well
so to get the scent strain it could take
you five hours
of just playing and that's to get
one bounty then the bounty could be like
go kill 40 champions and nightfalls
that's not going to be a short process
either because how many champions you
get
in a normal nightfall
so that's for one piece so when that
early 10 runs out then you guys finally
get to that like phase where like
hey we got some new sets coming i got a
couple things i want to work on that
reverie dawn did look pretty good let me
go grind that out
i'll talk to you guys in like two weeks
of playtime knocking out your bounties
and stuff like that and then you take
like the average person who's like
hey i have been playing off and on over
years here's some cool stuff but i want
to work on the other stuff
i mean you take five hours of game time
for some people that might be their
entire week
and that's one piece of gear then they
got to go do the bounty
and then you got this the multiple
currencies and things of that nature so
i think
right now if you get the little buffer
of like 10 and stuff like that it's not
so bad
but later on i think as that cap stays
if people still do want to actually when
the grind hits you in the face
and it's going to now if you haven't
played in a while you might have like
750 cent strand like stored up
and then you go buy a couple bounties
then you got to do those but it's like
it's gonna be the point where if you
want to intentionally go after it it's
not worth it it is so
long that if you do want to grind you
basically can't
i just thought it's so funny what's up i
got this funny feeling what they gonna
do
like you know how we got double infamy
and double valor week
bro i just thought about it i was like
yo double since week double sip
week son get in there
oh my god don't tell me it would be
funny it is so
budgie
last three weeks of the season when all
the grand masters are unlocked
that is your double since we've grinded
right
what a great marketing tool bro that's
how you do it
but the idea is for your tent like after
the season of your initial 10
every season you get a max of tens you
are capped you guys have agreed you
could remove the cap but in that season
of 10
it's 60 hours per character jesus yes a
lot
that's a lot of hours now some of us
play way way more than we should and
we'll probably hit that
and then you'll knock out the bounties
but for an average person to grind that
is just like
that is an impassable wall for somebody
who is
much more on the shorter play time and
you push them into the monetary
so it's like as you've seen like so many
different games have come out with like
different cosmetic system looks like
anthem
rested soul but you could literally
paint your armor put textures on you
could do whatever you wanted
nothing you could do that and
occasionally they'd come out with stuff
but it was like
cosmetics are a weird thing and i think
for me is what bugged me i guess the
most is the fact that we waited so
like transmog has literally been asked
for since like day one
because people came from stuff like
world of warcraft and other things and
rpgs and you've been able to mess with
your appearance and people and has to be
like hey this is cool
can't i mess with my appearance though
and it's been asked and asked nest and
finally when it comes out
it's like the convolute it's like you
have also three currencies i'm like
why do i have to earn three currencies
to take one back there to do a bounty to
get another currency to buy a symphony
of like
let me just earn the synth or just like
buy the bounty with whatever you want
and then just straight go it's like they
have even extra steps that seem
unnecessary somebody was like
there's only like one step in here can
we make it just a little more convoluted
so they really just gotta go talk to
tess
like one step would be like if you had
to go do a long ass grind for whatever
it is like
that'd be a time grind but if it's like
there's two other things in here
now you got a bounty system and more
it's just the point where like
they added so much on it's just like
somebody was joking and be like how bad
can we make this
yeah and it's just when you get into
that part of the system you're like
it does seem a bit ludicrous to unders
to like 60 hour grinds to buy these
bounties and those bounties like
i need 40 champions like well if i go do
like you know a hero nightfall that i
can at least match make until i get like
four so i gotta go run 10 more
nightfalls
i don't know how long that's gonna take
after i do the other 50 precision kills
with rocket launchers
[Laughter]
so it's just that weird system is like
for me personally
i'm not really going to work mess with
it that much i've got a lot of ornaments
that i've accumulated from seasons and
other things
i'll work on making something work
there's enough shaders that's fine
but for something that so the people who
do want to
you know dress up their characters as
dress me as literally a phrase that
seems to have caught on it's
it's like the worst system that's
probably been implemented for transmog
yeah it's the it's the out of all the
games i've played the most
games it is probably the worst system
for it or it's just
gonna be buy it but it's just like the
system is in there is so
ridiculously implemented there has to
have been like
you know somebody saying you got to do
this it's like nope it's still too short
well okay we've only got one currency we
need at least three
um bounties in there you gotta make sure
they wanted their bounties give them
their bounties like
that's that's i mean that's a d flawless
skit right there
pretty much that's literally it you know
but it's it's just that's
it it's oh you missed that one then no
no no i watched it i was like
that's kind of it is like if you go
through and they're like so for 10 items
this season
it's 180 hours if you want all 10 for
your three characters
so many people do not have that much
time to play season you can engage with
the story
the missions stuff like that and you're
not going to scratch the surface of 180
hours
at all so it's just very very strange
and when this first tin comes out and if
they don't touch it
like there's going to be more be like
people this like this grind sucks like
that's going to come up when those early
free time come out when they start
hitting the wall
it's going to start coming up so it's
just it's
it's one of those like i mean tassie was
like i didn't like it originally and
then now that it's out it's worse than
you even thought and you're like how how
do you make it worse
so yeah yeah i just i had to say it had
to address what the community is saying
i was like because the time gaining they
did the math on it it's like it's hours
and hours and hours to get your 10
180 hours each season if you want to do
your 10 pieces and it's just like
okay that's that's an interesting
decision
or tess is just going to be driving up
in a bentley next season because people
can sell it
because tess is lit test is going to be
late yeah i mean again
we we all agree you know like i said the
implementation needs to be way better
you know the grind needs to be cut and
then you get a lot of uh less pushback
but
my my gut tells me the over under on
this actually changing
i i just don't see it and not that i
justify it i'm not justifying it i'm
just saying
the way they're structured and you know
no daddy activision
you know it's them so they're gonna
i i'm telling you usually you know being
around corporations stuff like that
when when you get that silence from the
community
you know and and the um you know the
forward-facing people on bungie
and and it's because you know there was
that you know their hands yeah
who's controlling the money and cutting
the checks and i think sadly that's just
where it is and the way they can justify
and say look
this is cosmetic you know and that's
what they and again i'm not
no culture optional yeah i'm cosmetic
yup i'm not saying i'm just telling you
the thought process
as to why when we're yelling
on this issue they're not you know
really as receptive
yeah so i was like i definitely wanted
to talk about that one for sure
uh another thing that did arise has been
the sources of pinnacles
what is considered a pinnacle what's not
drop in pinnacle
obviously no vlog is coming up uh
some things aren't working correctly
like pressage should be dropping
pinnacles
it's not um yeah i think harbingers are
still working some of the others are
still there but the big one
and i wanted to get you guys thoughts
because my take gets to come last just
because i'm prompting the topic
deep stone crypt is no longer dropping
pinnacles and that's a
that's working correctly per bungie
for a bungee i was curious your guys
thoughts
get them flawless um
they they should change that it's it's
it's the current raid we get vlog it's
coming back you want people to play
vogue
make let vogue be pinnacle uh or make it
to where
you can choose one or the other and let
that be your pinnacle
um but if people want to run deep stone
crypt uh some people still don't have
eyes of tomorrow
so now you're making them run the raid
to try and get eyes of tomorrow
and if they need pinnacles they won't
get it they gotta they gotta do another
rape which is fine i mean i get you want
people to play your game but
it's it's still the current raid vlog is
a refresh
so i think i think uh i think deep stone
crypt should
should be pinnacle yeah said it couldn't
have said it any better i mean
i get it you know um i don't know
i get i'm talking again i'm talking
about i get
why they're doing it right because in
their eye
again corporate let me put my corporate
car going so you understand when i'm in
corporate car
all right like you're uh yeah so you
understand it's not it's not regular car
this corporate car
their mentality is well this is the new
raid
right and that that's you know we've
historically we've always done the new
raid against the pinnacle when the old
raid is
whatever whatever the problem is where i
agree and i'm regular cog now and i
agree with e is that this is revised
content right so in in this way that
part don't feel good that deep stone
doesn't offer that and it's not even my
argument
and me and you have always said that's
fine i'm curious
you guys are saying that that too it's
good right yeah my my thing is also that
we've always said even outside of that
there should be that raid of the week
playlist
where there's a pinnacle for doing a
damn raid because
this is your high-end content this is
the creme de la creme
you know if people do their damn space
walk and they've never done it and
people jump in there and see the beauty
of this content
you're going to be blown away you know
what i'm saying so the fact that they're
not pushing enough people into this
with that reward is to me a travesty in
itself you should get people in it
so you know i i i was surprised i was
surprised when people were like yo it
says pinnacle but i'm not getting it
and um yeah like it it feels weird like
you gotta get eyes tomorrow it's not a
pinnacle drop you're gonna get
all these cool weapons and it's not a
pinnacle drop and again no disrespect
the vog
vlog is gonna be great and i get why
that's a pinnacle
but it does feel weird that deep stone
has been demoted you know what i'm
saying
and and you don't really get that from
but i'm curious to hear what you got to
say
um be in reference to this whole thing
with uh
fog and the pinnacle aspect the
non-pinnacle aspect
of deep stone yeah i mean mine's not
even related to vog
mine is related deep stone crypts and
beyond light is a paid
expansion and flawless like i agree but
it was like you
paid 40 for the expansion
every single expansion previously that
expand that raid has held over before
for the pinnacle only time that probably
didn't happen was destiny one
and the only thing i can imagine is like
crota was the only way to go higher vog
wasn't going to get you to like 32
but at this point we paid now the other
side of that is
your exo mission that one's still a plus
two penalties that's
weird yeah you still got your master uh
what is the master what is the
lieutenant hunts or whatever they're
called i can't even remember
empire hunts and all the empire hearts
thank you yeah master empire that's
still a pinnacle that is all content
related to beyond light
that stuff's still pinnacle there's no
reason if those two are pinnacle
the deep stone crypt at all should not
be it's your raid it's your paid
expansion you paid 40 50 however much
seasons are optional and whether vog is
free or not
vog is an optional thing to do as you
said it's a reprised raid this is the
new fresh raid of this year
you paid this much money for it and if
you're going to take if somebody like
jumps in right now and they're like oh
cool like hey i'm free i jumped in the
seas well beyond light's got stasis and
stuff and this really cool raid
well i just bought it well you can't get
pinnacles from that anymore why they
just
what like so i mean there are multiple
issues with like
somebody could buy it more recently
trying to go after stasis
that's an issue because now this like
awesome raid as you said
that spacewalk is amazing but you also
take away the incentive as that pinnacle
grind is really the only thing this
season
right that really that pinnacle grind is
not going to matter
the 10 points this is still like the
whole leveling system is a discussion
for another day but the whole 10 points
like
oh they get through the 10 points too
fast vog is going to have contest mode
it's not going to matter for the first
day race it already doesn't matter
because they put it at 1300
so whether people are 13 10 13 15 13 18
13 20
that doesn't matter let them get there
how they want to get there you already
give like plus one pinnacles for doing a
strike
god forbid deep stone crypt is a raid
gives you plus two like
that doesn't make sense doesn't make any
does that make sense you already
stripped enough raids out of there
you're giving one free one back but deep
stone crypt
being the paid expansion also sets a bad
bar if which queen is like hey this
raid's only gonna be
pinnacle for six months until they bring
back taken king
and king's fall into there and then now
king's fall is going to be the pinnacle
ray and the witch queen the badass
newest one
not the old thing from d1 that even if
it's my favorite
like vog and like last wish the amount
of mechanics in there
those are not on the same level and
we'll have to see how much they make it
but like
last wish is like crazy in-depth crazy
dragon streaming city
all of it and you're like dude this is
an amazing piece of the expansion you
want to level up
yeah go do that old one from like six
years ago right it's
just a weird take on and again somebody
in my chat was saying it too it was like
when the exo mission's a plus two still
and that thing takes me like
10 minutes a week to do it yeah master
nightmare hunter like
all the other beyond like content still
they're hidden
and like you know the seas all that
stuff's still there so it's like no this
was
honestly just a bad bad take personally
i don't know
i get you i think what we call it is
forced engagement
where they they're pushing you towards
var
right and i feel you eating i'm not
pushing people away from deep stone
crypt which is an issue
yeah clearly clear and again to me it's
a travesty that in that respect because
especially with raids i'm always going
to say ray
is what literally made me play destiny
what made me stick with destiny was when
i did vault to class for the first time
it was amazing the community has not so
much of the community has not played it
so why what what's the purpose of it
right to remove it
from that especially when you got
something like that exo simulation thing
yeah you know which is so quick still
being a pinnacle
ray's in my opinion should have never
lose pinnacle status because it's such
a an engagement it's a six play and it's
a non-match made activity so
yeah you know i'm with you i'm
definitely with you on that
i don't know why they don't want to
value the raid that way
it doesn't make sense to me so even if
you just want to limit the
amount of pinnacle drops you can get
from raids in general so just
like keep all the raids and let's say
you have five
pinnacle drops that you can get from a
raid or whatever
the number may be if i want to do the f
the opening part of one raid do the
second part of another raid and do all
that but once i reach my five pinnacles
i got my five pinnacles let me do that
exactly you know exactly um you know
like you said it's it's
a raid it's a six-man you got to find a
fire team it requires coordination and
all this other stuff
and there's stuff that's so much easier
to do in the game that's rewarding
pinnacles
just why take it away at all uh if you
want to put a cap on it that's fine
um but let me do whatever i want to do
yep
i completely agree question e did you
say did they they didn't take the spoils
out right is it spoilers
i've heard those are gone too oh no
oh oh no
if chat can correct or something i'll
see if i can look at my discord but yeah
there is
a list of what got ripped out and i
think that was in there too if i
remember correctly i'd have to look and
see
hopefully that's a glitch right
all right do you want foreign
last wish at all are they just gonna be
like you can only get spoils from vlog
like i don't understand quite what's
happening so
so that would be a major ooh no
no no because at the end of the day for
the people who
missed out on prior raid stuff
that you could only get through spoils
you can't you
wow you gotta only go through one
specific raid to get that
i don't know all i know is i heard they
were taken out of the deep stone crypt
so no spoils and no pinnacles like
why go on the spacewalk it sounds cool
but you're wasting your time almost
i mean yeah there's cool weapons there
don't get me wrong gotta get away
there's no way that's intentional i i'm
gonna i'm gonna
i'm gonna believe better of bungie i
gotta hope
i gotta hope i'm like you're like
but i mean they literally came out and
said like when it comes to the patch
where's the list of crap that pissed me
off
uh known issues press objectivity is not
rewarding pinnacles as intended
okay that one is supposed to be deep
stone crypt no longer awards pinnacles
but lists that it does it's literally
saying it right there
like it no longer awards pinnacles a
very deliberate decision
now it doesn't say anything about spoils
i haven't seen any bug about that
specifically mentioned
but somebody in chat uh the real duran
is saying that they're not i've seen it
somewhere else too in a couple places
about it so
it's it's a weird weird weird decision i
i don't understand some of it could be a
glitch but the choice to take away the
pinnacles is
as you said not necessary i don't care
when you get your five pinnacles
from raid sources you count them out you
take checkpoints i don't care but like
i'm looking at the floor if you go play
last wish and you do it for real
you should get pinnacles in there too
like if you beat
all right so it looks like just for
clarity i'm looking at the bungee forums
and people are
um asking hey spoils from you know deep
stone and people are
the vibe i'm getting is that they've
been lessened
that they do exist but somebody said it
might be like 12 from the final boss and
stuff
yeah like they said full run got him 20
full run today
got him to so maybe maybe it's an issue
where
yeah i'm looking at oh but these dates
are old on this so i don't know
maybe that myth may not be current we
need to know currently if anyone's run
deep stone
you know what's going on shout out to
back from dead that's my clan mate
that's that's my guy he said now i have
no reason to carry climbing
exactly because one of the cool things
about the spoil system is even if you
did the raid you got the pinnacle
if you ran it again just for the sense
of being a sherpa which backfired is one
of the greatest sherpas and i don't know
a podcast clan salute to my brother
but um you always felt like you got
something out of it right you're like
okay i got raised boils out of this
i could work on stuff yeah that that's
got to be
i hope that's a glitch that that that
cannot be
yikes we got to look into that y'all
that that would be a major
snafu if that is intentionally done
so yeah um
so yeah we start out the season not too
shabby get some fallen stuff
over it's kind of cool kind of gambity
but we got new weapons that are cool
stasis aspects start breaking pvp
we got boots that just dropped that made
titans like
now like the stasis counterpart of crazy
fire two taps and
then you got transmog fires and these
it's a weird like tale of two coins
as usual with bungie and destiny is
the i hate the phrase of you know two
steps forward and two steps back or
however you want like
two steps forward one step back it's
like we got some like the narrative
stuff like man i can't wait to see where
the story goes
seeing the expunge mission coming up
like each week we're gonna see it i
don't even know how many varieties or
what's gonna be told in there
i'm excited to see that so if that's
like eight weeks of stuff
not really caring too much when it comes
to solstice that is just the summer
event it's gonna be what it is we kind
of know what to expect
they don't expect any major changes
before between because just like the
other
seasonal activities whether they mate
whether they got cut or whether they
make it or not we'll just have to see
but i don't expect anything there so the
story is cool so what's again going to
tide us over
we'll have to see how the world of
stasis and trials and stuff there's a
new trials
smg i think i haven't seen all the perks
on that one so i'll be curious if that
one has some fun rolls
got a seven i hope it's a 750 i don't
remember
but yes and then also the smalling how
many how many pre-ordered their plushies
i'll attempt i swear too late it's
probably going now if i try to get it
well
i mean no you can't pre-order i think i
just got the email list but yeah
okay they are going to they better make
as many as possible we can those are
going to sell out
like yeah whatever smallin plushies
hatchlings are in there they are 100
percent gonna be
sold out i will tell you it is in his
bag right now
no doubt but for you guys after about
you know three three and a half days or
so
what do you guys think what are your do
you have high hopes for the season you
think you got a feel for it now where
are you guys at so far
yeah i do i do i think i think
pvp aside this season
is phenomenal from loot to lore to
the activity um to
looks like they have a nice road map
ahead of us
um this this season
for me is you know a four out of five
you know with the
with the one part being the the pvp
and the unnecessary kind of tone def
buffs to stasis but
um you know so i'm excited
i can't wait to see where it goes i want
to see the story i want to check out all
the new overrides
all the new weapons you know they're
going to have some secrets there vaulted
glass is going to be fun
um i think it's a good season so far
what's up yeah man um you know
it's it's listen it's it's not we're in
the honeymoon phase baby
you know well you know we chilling you
know it's new content i always love
where the new season start you know see
what's going on six man activity i'm a
fan of i'm waiting to see what uh vlog
does
obviously yeah we have some snafus like
just like flawless said you know
we've got to see how this is my main
thing is narrative narrative keep on
driving at home keep on
you know i wanted to i hope i would like
for them to keep a nice cadence
how they did with uh season of the
chosen where every week you tune in like
yo all right what happened this week
okay
you know crow is this cato said this and
you know what i'm saying so i want to
know you know what's going to happen
do we get constant communication with
mythrax you know what's going on with
our cora the whole bit and um
like i like lakshmi's involvement and
see where else it goes
with with this voice acting and what
else they want to do with this lore so
that that's what i'm in for you know i'm
saying i know where you at as far as you
know after a while how many more of
these overrides been going
i know i know i i i i feel you i i know
where you at mr harcourt i get it
but for me it's always been about the
lore and when when they
when they do law right like last season
was
proof of it it kept me engaged it made
me tune in on reset
every time to see and i and and to your
credit i want to see what they do for
you for um
these uh you know what is it what they
call it the pinnacle mission yeah
expunge the weekly pinnacle
yeah i'm curious what to see what they
do for it and um
i'm very curious at the end what the
hell is epilogue i am
that what is that like what i've died
maybe that's another
event like uh the another tower event no
i was like
you know that would need to be something
like tower event or
almighty new york what yeah yeah
a little simulation of the thing
breaking the
sun it doesn't take how many hours did
it take last time
it was an hour and a half it was 90
minutes it was a bit stretched so
yeah you know what you may be on or
something that might be exactly
it i could totally see that because we
got to break the simulation we got to
break this thing that's stopping the sun
from coming
bam flawless with the exclusive
exclusive
yeah uh and then also tangled shore has
this weird little like kind of secret
stuff going on right now that's like
seems to be time-gated
the lost sector and then basically the
starting location for the brood hold
strike have these little like vex
confluxes
just like chilling like if you go clean
out the kingship doc lost sector
if you clean it out little transmog or
the conflict shows up
and if you interact with it the diamonds
that used to be on mercury when you were
doing the public event to try and get it
to heroic and you had to like
shoot the couple and shoot the thing
yeah five of those appear
kill all five a minotaur appears right
now
doesn't do anything and then if you load
in the brood hold strike one of those
sometimes is at the starting location i
know because i spawned in it once on
accident so
but outside of spawning into something
you ain't supposed to be no i didn't
even know somebody's like hey it's at
this location i drove over there
nothing there and like well they're set
up at the start of the strike so i went
into the strike specifically on the
director
and checked and i was like well i was
actually in it so i was like okay i
found it but it's like it's not always
there but the one in the lost sector you
can repeat
just go into kingship dock it's right
there unlike the main area next to
spider
you go up clear it out as soon as you
clear it all conflux appears
every time so there's something with
that
um so probably time gated some some way
nature as you guys said
we're gonna get a couple locations for
override we're gonna get a couple other
bosses so that's gonna happen
um this whole year
the narrative has been fantastic the
narrative the story
understanding cesis and the exos and
clovis
and elsie and then kyle last season and
mythrax in the fall and this season
i'm loving what they're doing with the
story the narrative and things like that
my question is for me
and again this will just be everybody
different and depends on you know kind
of the state of things
is this the tuesday login as you said
experience the story see what's up with
the new weekly pinnacle mission
or is there much more after that and
again between variety and other things
to have a healthy relationship
with the game you know week five or six
when you're just waiting on the weekly
pinnacle
reset to see what's up with a new
mission that may be most of what you do
and then knock out your challenges for
the week and it may be
one day or two but it may not be like
every day so we'll see
there's some parts that i really enjoy
and then i hear the community on the
other side so it's uh
yeah i'm very curious and epilogue as
well
yeah very very intrigued by that one
like
chat's telling me they've like looked
into some stuff
and they're just like well some stuff
gets data mined and my chat every so
often is like uh
and i'm like just don't tell me so it's
like some of the stuff that could be
coming later
oh apparently it could be lots of fun so
i was like
there might be more that we don't know
there might be more that we don't know
so it's like
i'm always curious to see where it goes
i'll be there every tuesday without a
question as long as i'm in town
um so overall yeah pretty pumped very
curious
no doubt sadly i'm going to be out of
town for the epilogue start so hopefully
that's not too dramatic but we'll see
yeah care to explain nope i don't even i
don't even know that much because they
want you to start snitching no
i don't know that much in the first
place
[Laughter]
i don't know much intentionally so let's
go pick up that stadium yeah i got to
get that um you know
i got to get that developer access on
that stadia log and it's like so ebontus
underscore dev access password one two
three
let's go okay cool
well that's about what we got this week
um i can't think of too much else if you
guys got anything else right now
other than that d flawless man thank you
very much for coming on
um obviously keep doing what you're
doing but like
right now give us the exclusive what do
you got coming up
you know what new promotion who's your
next spot no i'm just kidding but
honestly
no but the floor is yours um just let
everybody know what you got going on
uh if you got any partnerships hit them
up everything just the floor is yours
tell it all yeah no just uh we kind of
mentioned it you know you can just
follow me on the socials on twitter
at dd flawless uh youtube we're doing a
lot of variety
there we'll be checking out mass effect
uh some other games
um on the youtube channel that's where
you're going to see a lot of my variety
content
um and the main you know the the bulk of
the flawless content can be found at
twitch.tv slash
d flawless where we're you know playing
games uh running skits
talking with talking with the flawless
family you'll you'll get to see them
on the channel um as far as partnership
sponsors you know just advanced gg baby
use cold flaws
fast gg but that's about it
you know of course i'm always working on
stuff but can't really talk about
everything
but my my biggest thing that i like to
say and it's really the truth
if i'm quiet it's because i'm working on
something so just if
you don't see me right here for me oh
flawless is cooking something up
but that that's about it just follow me
on those socials and i hope to see you
in chat
follow him on twitter and at least
you'll see his tick tocks that way but
yeah go
go follow this man tick tocks you'll get
the uh the hilarious takes of the bungie
community
the flawless on tick tock yeah yeah
shout out to flawless man i mean
you've been killing it and um one thing
i like like i said
just what you bring to the community
like just you know
i look forward to your takes on some of
the spiciest topics in the better
some of the spiciest topics but you know
the communities fall around but you
always have a way to not only have your
finger on what's going on but to do it
in a funny way
and yo shout out to you i've been how i
sent people your schedule
yo you got to see this dude this is this
is this is hilarious and just to see
your ascension and your blessings
brother keep up the great work
you got a fantastic lane i love what
you're doing
and um day i'm glad you was able to come
on man i was really
looking forward to this one i was like
oh he made it happen like because the
community
i was like yeah we trying but i said i
don't e on it i said i know
so yeah shout out to you man thank you i
just wanna i just wanted to to kind of
go
to that just one of the because people
people aren't always smiles you know no
matter what people portray on the
internet it's impossible to be positive
and happy all the time people are going
to real problems so
facts if i can bring smiles and laughter
to people
just through my little one minute or
less videos
i don't we understand the issues it's a
video game at the end of the day we
understand the issues
i try to show both sides of each
argument whenever i
whenever i do these videos but i want
people to feel heard
and i want people to smile i want to
want to bring some laughter because
you never know what that can do for
somebody somebody could just be
struggling to hold it together
and being able to put a smile on their
face briefly you know it could
potentially save a life you know
i've i've had people tell me that i've
been able to help them through
really tough situations so as long as
i'm able to do that the videos and the
content will keep on coming because
that's what i love to do
nah bro keep it up it's fantastic and
what i like
too is i like that bungie's gotten
behind you too because
then they also showed me they're not
afraid to laugh at themselves
at some of the things that you do
because you never what i like about you
you never put anything
anybody in a disrespectful position
you're just having fun with it even
i think there was one that you i would i
get it so well done bro like you had the
jeopardy joint it was like
for
you're killing it and like you said
you'd be surprised
how many times you know someone's going
through a rough day or whatever but
just that erupting that laughter that
joy you bring with your content and your
character your character game is all
fine
man of multiple personalities and every
one of them's just like
all right what are you gonna do today uh
mama watched it and you're like oh man
no it's absolutely amazing yeah no it's
like we were trying to get you on for a
little while had a little you know
always got to get the scheduling worked
out so i'm glad we got you in
couldn't it be at a perfect time because
like definitely like to catch you as the
rocket ship
flies by because you're not going to
work
people talk to his people with the way
he going yeah like
can we like grapple on and just get
drunk
that's the best part is like it you just
been doing what you're doing
and then it's it's happening for
somebody who couldn't deserve it more
so working your tail off you're able to
go full time now i wanted to
congratulate you on this oh yes
the full-time flip over and then just
like the reception by the community and
everybody is just like
you're you're just a piece of it it's
it's fantastic to see
like basically a t like tick-tock
comedian
just as i mean cognito said it right
it's never
a mean take but it is just like the
perfect level of like
poking the bear just enough yes be like
you haven't pissed them off
you're basically making fun with them
and at them at the same time and you
like it
i try to bring that barbershop you know
like if you know especially if
barbershops families and things like
that you know bags
if i love you if i love you i'm gonna
make fun of you that's how
you feel that's what i'm from you know i
love bungie it's my destiny is my
favorite game
so that love is like you know bridge
familiarity
and i'm able to be like all right yo
bunji you tripping so like
what are the ones that you do well too
and i showed about people who don't play
destiny
i love when like another game is popping
and then you'll show
or you or you're an apex main now you
want to come back
like because i've had those beats with
people by people
right and it's like they'll leave and
then they want to come back and then you
did it the opposite way where
you're a bunch
because these are communal things that
as gamers
we do you know what i'm saying again
you've got it
down bro keep it up sky's the limit man
you
you're on your way bro you're on your
way keep it up brother thank you
appreciate y'all
no doubt absolutely [ __ ] what do you got
coming any fancy guests on ilp for the
sunday shows
we may be i'm not as fancy flawless but
we may have a little something oh
shout out yo it's gonna be a fun one man
check it out this week
um sunday i lost podcast 1 p.m eastern
the legendary informative journalist
jason schreier will be in the building
so we're going to talk about this new
book we're going to talk about press
start
i mean press reset excuse me press reset
that's the new book man check it out
it's
and it's good because you know you get
to learn about the flip side
about when our favorite shots of the car
is going by they they excited too
but you get to hear about the things in
the community when the um
you know when when studios go away you
know and as much as we complain about
bungie this and this that in the third
you know you see the flip side of
decisions going wrong and he's got some
great stories in his book i
highly recommend it also if you didn't
read the one before which is uh blood
sweat and pixels
that actually showed the origin of
destiny
and how this game almost it was a mess
he did barely could come out the door
and how they were able to scrape it
together and then now this thing become
a success so
yeah check us out it will be sunday 1
p.m eastern
ireland podcast channel it'll be great
and if you can check out the website
lordsgaming.net again we'll be doing
some real cool pieces called launch
minute e thank you for the love on that
and uh and shouting that out we've been
doing that with a lot of our writers
for the gamers by the gamers we're
talking about all different type of
subjects in the gaming community
and i'm trying to get more destiny stuff
going and um yeah you know check it out
man when you get a chance and of course
that last word podcast you know what i'm
saying the best podcast most people
don't know about you but
we try to get the word out before we try
to get the word out
i appreciate it i appreciate it but now
man i love doing this with e
and um again we have guests like this
it's always fun to look forward to it's
always exciting to get up and
do some fun stuff and uh yeah man a
great show great show good time in
destiny
more stuff to talk about what you got
going on
yeah for me um got some time to stream
this weekend work will be busy next week
but of course you know playing the crap
out of
this of course um grinding up seeing
what's going on this season very excited
for that you know
expunge mission because those weekly
pinnacle exotics those are always my jam
every time like those are probably my
favorite content is those
missions when you go through the solos
just that that experience that they
develop in those missions is
just stellar everything like just keep
getting better i feel like like last
time we had prestige it was like
it's literally alien in destiny like the
alien movie in destiny they just
absolutely crush it and then all of a
sudden like what's coming next and this
time we're gonna go play around in tron
or something who knows so
those are always exciting and then of
course you know um
i'm waiting on a monitor to like go for
like the high res fun stuff
i want to get a new monitor to either go
like 4k 60 or 144
because i want to play like um
horizon zero dawn death stranding mass
effect i want to play those at like 4k
yeah yeah gmd and i are working on those
i talk to him all the time like gmd
geeks a huge like nerd
with me i was like i i've been on
60 frames per second for way too long so
it's like i want to see what the new
lights like and also i want to play like
you know
console is going to give me 4k 60. i
want to see what that looks like so
i haven't even touched hdr so like when
that comes
there's some games that i want to
experience and i've been holding back on
those like
all on pc like horizon death stranding
uh controls another one and then mass
effect now coming there's
there's some big stuff that i'm looking
forward to but you also got bio mutant
coming up in like
11 days it's such a goofy looking like
hot like animal collection but like the
crafting
looks nuts like oh you want to build
another deal with the game's about i
just want to know i just wanna
play it like you're gonna take like a
barrel and a stock and shove it together
and then you got the attachment here and
a weird scope i don't even know if you
can shove rockets or bullets or energy
in there
you've got like psionics going on if you
change your character's
intelligence the head gets bigger if you
change the agility and when your
character creator is ridiculous like if
you change ability
they get to be a little like taller and
lean and lanky like
if you get stronger obviously you're a
little bit it's just i was like it looks
like the goofiest little kind of open
world advent like i love stuff like that
man it looks so fun like so that's going
to be a variety stream
for sure um whether i get to cover it on
my own dollar or not it's
it's going to come through the channel
um so that one looks very
yeah no micro transactions looks pretty
cool so
that one will be probably in a week or
two so we'll get closer to that next
week but yeah go check out bio mutant
just
it if it sounds like you know third
person kind of action adventure you've
got some shooting you've got some melee
you've got a little bit of magic little
rpg
and i don't even know what the hell the
story is going to be about you're like
some goofy mechanical
like you look like a raccoon half the
time but like a mechanic
you look probably like rocket raccoon is
the best way i can say is like
the rocket raccoon rpg
yeah goofy ass game but seems like a ton
of fun uh so that'll be coming
uh and then in june we've got ratchet
and clank which looks like a pixar movie
oh yeah and then so yeah there's i'm
never gonna run out of stuff to try and
keep playing so of course the variety is
going to be here but
now i was like we started the story well
i'm very curious to see where the story
goes this season because
like you can have issues over pvp or
stasis or transmog
but i am hooked on this destiny story
like
since beyond light and then title and
now this one like i i've got i
have to know where the story goes i am
so hooked so
i'm with you now bungie bungie's
crushing it uh on some fronts and then
you know we'll give them their feedback
on others hopefully we can meet in the
middle
but man same thing i want to shout out
uh sir flawless thank you
we appreciate it um absolute blast
chatting with you just as fun
watching you as having you in here the
hot takes were had to be had
keep doing what you're doing it is
amazing um thank you very much for
joining us it was our pleasure
thank you likewise uh but that's pretty
much what we got for this episode guys i
will probably be streaming something
later
um so go find ilp on sunday i know d
flawless will be out there he's full
time he's putting the work in
uh go buy some advanced gg use code
flawless anti
all of them type them all in and you get
40 off
maybe get 40 off if you type them all in
i don't know how it works but
put on go get some advanced gg um it's
tasty stuff i can definitely vouch for
that one
and that's about all we got so for
episode number 149
150 is next week we actually hit 150
next week and we are gonna go
og we bring in mark turcotte of guardian
radio on
uh we're gonna bring him back so we
gotta gotta hit it in the feels there
for the 150
perfect episode and he hasn't been in it
as much so it'll be good to get a bit of
an outsider's take but he's always kind
of up on it he can't ever quite get away
so
that'll be tomorrow or not tomorrow
it'll be next week same time
nine a.m back to back back-to-back
episodes
tough ship over here yeah no that'll be
next week same time morning show so tune
in for that one if you guys made it to
the end of the podcast thank you if you
follow us on audio video follow like
drop a review on itunes whatever it is
you guys do thank you guys very much
uh but for this episode it has been
awesome so we will wrap this thing up
episode number 149 for may 14th guest d
flawless has been fantastic and it has
been
the last word